Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Sieh mal, wie sie sich an die Worte anbauen.
Sieh mal, wie sie sich anbauen.
Und damit ist es wieder einmal soweit. Der letzte Mittwoch im Monat ist angekommen. Und das heißt an dieser Stelle gibt es zwei Stunden Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Das heißt das Radio, wo der Chaos Computer Club selber und direkt mitwirkt, ist eigentlich auch falsch. Der es macht heute in Gestalt von Konstanze Kurz, die hier zu Gast ist. Guten Abend. Und hast noch jemand mitgebracht, nämlich Jörg Pohle von der Humboldt Universität Berlin. Und wir wollen heute über etwas reden, was ihr digitale Postkarten genannt habt.
Genau.
Da weiß man jetzt sozusagen als normalsterblich erstmal nicht, worum es geht. Digitale Postkarten ist das so eine Art Foto, was ich auch als Postkarte verschicken kann. Nein, wir reden darüber, was ihr vielleicht gerade so eben im Fernsehen als Werbung gesehen habt, über die sogenannte e-Post oder bzw. De-Mail oder Die-Mail. Gibt es da ein offizielles, offizielle Sprachregelung?
Es sind zwei Projekte und die Post, die ja jetzt überall die Werbung hat, die hat es e-Postbrief genannt. Und die offizielle Bezeichnung, die auch schon länger im Umlauf ist, ist De-Mail. Aber da wollte sich die Post eben auch namentlich jetzt unterscheiden und hat einen eigenen Namen gefunden. Aber jetzt von Gesetzgebungsverfahren und da steckt auch der Staat hinter, da ist eigentlich der Überbegriff Bürgerportal. Das werden wir nachher aufdröseln, damit wir auch verstehen, worüber wir eigentlich reden und warum die Projekte unterschiedlich heißen.
Okay, da haben wir jetzt zwei Stunden Zeit zu. Erstmal noch zum Chaosradio ist zu sagen, ihr könnt auf jeden Fall mitmachen. Es gibt einen Chat, es gibt einen Wiki, es gibt einen Twitter-Account, da heißt Chaosradio, dem könnt ihr alle irgendwie Nachrichten zukommen lassen, wenn ihr was zur Sendung sagen wollt. Und natürlich funktioniert auch noch das gute alte, analoge Telefon. 0331 70 97 110 Denn wir wollen natürlich von euch heute wissen, wie es denn aus mit diesen ganzen digitalen neuen E-Mails, die ja auch Geld kosten sollen, aber ganz sicher sein sollen, euch Bürokram erleichtern, werdet ihr die nutzen oder nicht. Eigentlich würde ich es spannend finden, wenn Leute jetzt gleich anrufen und sagen, ja ja, finde ich super, und dann reden wir zwei Stunden drüber und dann fragen wir nochmal. Aber gut, kommen wir zum grundlegenden, wie heißt das, Bürgerportal?
Ja, wir wollen vielleicht mal so ein bisschen umreißen, was ist das eigentlich? Ja, nicht und jetzt, sondern was wir eigentlich heute machen wollen, weil das Projekt ist so groß geworden, dass man fast ein paar Stunden drüber reden konnte, und wir müssen uns ein bisschen beschränken. Wir werden zum einen darüber reden, was ist das, wie unterscheiden sich diese Projekte, was macht es eigentlich technisch, was sind die typischen Kritikpunkte, die so zu äußern sind, wem nützt das eigentlich, sowohl kommerziell, wie aber auch vielleicht auf einer anderen Ebene, wo ist das eigentlich hilfreich und wo nicht. Wie sieht es aus mit der rechtlichen Seite? Da haben wir unseren Spezialexperten dabei, der wird vor allen Dingen Jörg brillieren können. Dann werden wir auch noch ein bisschen darüber reden, wie sehen die Zukunftschancen aus? Zum Ende wollen wir darauf kommen zu sagen, hat das eine Zukunft, warum hat es eine Zukunft? Ist das vielleicht sogar eine Dystopie, die uns da erwartet, oder ist das gut für uns oder nicht?
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn es um neue technische Systeme geht, die vom Start organisiert werden und über die der Chaos Computer Club eine Radiosendung macht, würde ich ihr zu letzterem tendieren.
Ja, wir sind natürlich kritisch. Also natürlich, klar, es gibt mehrere, paar Dutzend technische Richtlinien dazu, die man auch alle runterladen kann.
Okay, warte, warte, bevor wir zu technischen Richtlinien kommen, können wir es einfach mal einfach machen? Was ist das eigentlich?
Also die Grundidee hinter sowohl dem E-Postbrief wie auch der E-Mail ist, eine gewisse Gleichwertigkeit herzustellen zwischen dem bekannten Konzept von einem Papierbrief und elektronischer Kommunikation. Das ist mal so eine ganz grobe Grundidee. Man will halt vor allen Dingen auf der juristischen Ebene so die Fragen der Rechtssicherheit, wenn ich jemanden verchecke, da will man versuchen, so eine Art Gleichwertigkeit herzustellen. Das ist die ganz grobe Idee. Die gehört zur Hightech-Strategie der Bundesregierung, also ist in so einem großen Plan einsortiert und soll zum einen Behörden helfen, Dienstlässern helfen und natürlich Bürgern. Das heißt, insbesondere geht es um Kommunikation und wie kann man die irgendwie rechtssicher gestalten? Das haben sie also versucht, in Konzepte zu gießen.
Also ich vermute sozusagen, ich kriege meine Knöllchen demnächst per E-Mail zugestellt.
Per die E-Mail. Zu der Unterscheidung kommen wir noch gleich, denn was wir jetzt alle im Fernsehen sehen, ist natürlich erstmal die Post, weil die so ein bisschen früher an den Start ging mit ihrem sogenannten E-Postbrief.
Ist es jetzt denn dasselbe oder gibt es da Unterschiede? Oder sollten wir erst klären, was die einzelnen Sachen überhaupt machen?
Also wir können zumindest mal kurz sagen, was die Post damit zu tun hat. Bis letzten Sommer haben die da mitgespielt bei De-Mail. Und dann gab es wohl irgendwelchen Knatsch, wobei ein bisschen unklar ist, worum es da ging. Und jetzt versucht die Post ein fertiges System zu präsentieren und Leute einzusammeln, die ihr System nutzen, damit sie schon einfach viele Kunden hat, bevor die E-Mail an den Start geht.
Genau. Das ist sozusagen quasi jetzt eine Konkurrenz geworden und sollte mal ein gemeinsames Projekt werden. Aber prinzipiell soll diese De-Mail, egal in welcher Form, ob sie jetzt e-Postbrief heißt oder De-Mail heißt, von bestimmten Anbietern für alle Bürger oder eben für ihre Kunden angeboten werden. Im Amtsdeutsch heißt es Bürgerportaldiensteanbieter, schön in Beamtendeutsch. Und das sind zum einen eben die Post, die schon angefangen hat, aber das andere Konsortium ist United Internet. Das sind die Betreiber von Web.de und GMX, also ziemlich bekannte Dienstleister im Mail-Service-Bereich und die Telekom. Und über die Telekom lief auch der große Test, der sich über sechs Monate hingezogen hat. Also die haben natürlich mal probiert, funktioniert die Technik, wie wird sie angenommen, dann haben sie eine Akzeptanzstudie gemacht, das übliche, was vor so großen Projekten gemacht wird. Jetzt ist nur eben die Post ein bisschen vorgeprescht und hat einen eigenen E-Postbrief vorgestellt. Die Probleme, auf die wir noch kommen, sind natürlich bei beiden ähnlich.
Okay, aber wir kommen jetzt erst mal zurück zum Anfang. Ich bin jetzt in Zukunft De-Mail-Nutzer. Wie genau sieht das aus?
Also, wie du dich registrierst?
Also ich sitze vor meinem Rechner und dann, genau, ich registriere mich irgendwie, ich verstehe dann irgendwie Mails, ich bekomme Mails, die sozusagen dann auch als, sozusagen wie ein Einschreiben von der Behörde gelten. Wie genau funktioniert das?
Willst du oder soll ich, also wir können mal vielleicht von der Benutzersicht anfangen. Also überlegen, wie soll das aussehen? Also wie man Behördenpost auf Papierwege kriegt, kennt man ja entweder normales Schreiben, bei der Briefkasse entstanden, oder eben ein Einschreiben, was ich in der Regel abhole oder mir jedenfalls auf einem Wege zugestellt wird, wo derjenige, der das Einschreiben abgeschickt hat, auch eine Bestätigung bekommt. Und dies soll technisch übertragen werden auf elektronische Kommunikation. Das heißt, was ich praktisch tue, ist, ich loge mich in ein Portal ein, ein Bürgerportal, nehme mal beispielhaft die Post, kann aber auch bei Web.de sein. Habe mich natürlich vorher registriert. Und da kann ich quasi jetzt genau wie auf meinen Briefkasten zugreifen. Das ist der Plan. Und etwa zum Beispiel schreiben, die von juristischen Belangen sind. Nehmen wir mal einen Steuerbescheid oder dergleichen. Oder vom Bauamt, vom Arbeitsamt, vom Jugendamt dort in Empfang nehmen. Und da ist es nämlich nicht nur so, dass es quasi wie bei einer E-Mail ist, kommt irgendwann an, sondern es gibt eine Bestätigung des Empfangs, sodass eben derjenige, der das abgeschickt hat, sicher sein kann oder sicher sein soll, dass diese die E-Mail angekommen ist. Es gibt aber keine Möglichkeit zu sagen, wann derjenige das abruft, sondern eben nur es ist zugestellt worden an diese Bürgerportale, an den jeweiligen Anbieter, eben web.de oder...
Also es liegt in meinem Briefkasten drin quasi.
Genau, in deinem virtuellen Briefkasten. Das ist so ungefähr der Plan aus Nutzer-Sicht.
Das hört sich jetzt aber genauso an, als ob es ein, also genauso einfach ist wie E-Mail. Gibt es irgendwelche Unterschiede?
Aus Nutzer-Sicht soll das auch eher so aussehen, als wäre das E-Mail. Aber die beiden hängen nicht miteinander zusammen. Also man kann nicht gleichzeitig mit einer normalen E-Mail-Adresse an eine De-Mail-Adresse schreiben. Und man kann, soweit wir das sehen, auch nicht gleichzeitig von einer De-Mail-Adresse an eine E-Mail-Adresse schreiben. Also die beiden sind getrennte Systeme. Man könnte sozusagen sich hinstellen und behaupten, die E-Mail ist so was wie die deutsche Version von E-Mail und die ist getrennt. Wir haben jetzt endlich getrennte Netze.
Nein, stimmt natürlich nicht so ganz. Also die wollen das wirklich trennen. Das heißt, man soll da keine normalen E-Mail mit verschicken können, sondern das hat da jetzt tatsächlich für rechtsgültige Schreiben geplant.
Also der, sozusagen mein analoger Briefkasten in der Hausliste ist ganz überflüssig, weil dann nur noch Werbepost reinkommt, weil die Behördenpost dann über das De-Mail-Postfach kommt. Das soll aber sozusagen zumindest von der Einfachheit her, wie normales Mail-Programm funktionieren ist. Aber ihr habt gesagt Webportal, das gibt es nicht auf dem Rechner.
Also bisher ist es doch zumindest in der Testregion, die in Friedrichshafen war, für sechs Monate, da gab es sozusagen keine Möglichkeit von POP3. Also du konntest dich nicht auf ein Mail-Client holen, sondern musst eben immer dieses Webportal anzursurfen. Das ist aber für viele ein User, glaube ich, nicht so ungewöhnlich. Es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Leute, die das sowieso machen.
Also es gibt verpflichtende Auflagen für die Bürgerportaldienstanbieter und dazu gehört so ein Web-Client und die anderen sind freiwillig. Die können die anbieten, aber sie müssen nicht.
Genau. Das heißt, was wäre da noch?
Na, einen Zugriff mit einem ganz normalen E-Mail-Client.
Das kann angeboten werden, muss aber nicht.
Das kann angeboten werden.
Okay, aber ich meine im Prinzip hört sich das jetzt auf den ersten Blick ganz gut an, weil also okay, ich muss zwar ins Internet, aber es muss ich sowieso, wenn ich irgendwie E-Mails lese und ich kriege meinen ganzen Papierkram nicht mehr auf Papier, sondern halt per Netz, muss aber auch bezahlen.
Richtig, dann haben wir noch nicht erwähnt. Die ganze Sache ist kostenpflichtig und zumindest, ja, bei der Post wissen wir jetzt den Preis. Bei den anderen Anbietern wird der Preis wohl da runter liegen.
Also die Post verlangt 55 Cent.
Genau.
Wie für einen ganz normalen Brief, nur dass der angeblich mehr Eigenschaften hat, aber über die werden wir noch reden. Und die anderen reden so von Preisen um die 15 Cent.
Ja, 15 ist 19. Also es soll auf jeden Fall ein bisschen preiswerter sein. Das wird natürlich vielleicht dann ein bisschen volatil, da werden sich die Preise vielleicht noch ändern.
Aber was ich verstehe, ist die Post doch gerade nicht mit dem offiziellen Dinge am Start, sondern macht ihr eigenes Gerät und das offizielle De-Mail, was also für Behörden auch bei den anderen...
Was heißt offiziell? Offiziell wird es dann, wenn es eine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt, damit diese Rechtssicherheit auch in Gesetzform tritt. Das ist ein Bürgerportalgesetz und ist derzeit noch in der Mache. Das heißt, kein Anbieter, weder die Konkurrenten noch die Post, können derzeit tatsächliche Rechtssicherheit anbieten. Es ist aber trotzdem so, dass die Post mit der Voranmeldung, mit der Registrierung jetzt begonnen hat. Es ist jetzt an den Start gegangen und offenbar gibt es auch einige Menschen, die da die Werbung, also na ja, die sich da anmelden. Da kommt man nochmal auf die Details nachher.
Wir haben jetzt einen Dienst, der verschickt Mails, die aber so sicher sein soll wie Briefe, kostet auch erstmal genauso viel, zumindest das, was sie jetzt schon wissen. Und das ist insofern praktisch, als ich in Zukunft den ganzen Behörden Kram am Rechner machen kann, was jetzt nicht so schlimm für sich für mich anhört.
Na nicht praktisch. Also da geht es schon darum, dass du was sicher zugestellt bekommen kannst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel einen Bescheid von der Behörde kriegst, dann wird es heute dir natürlich ein paar Posten geschickt. Du kriegst ja in der Regel also ein Briefbrief, also auf Papier, Tote im Baum. Und dann sollte ihm voll elektronisch irgendwelche Medienbrüche so natürlich in einer etwas ferneren Zukunft vermieden werden. Das heißt, zwischendurch soll nichts mehr ausgedruckt werden. Das klappt jetzt noch nicht. Bei dem Test war es natürlich so, dass sie zwischendurch wieder Formulare ausgedruckt haben und wieder eingescannt haben. Also der Test ist immer natürlich in der Tatsache.
Ja, na gut, aber das ist ja das, was ich als praktisch empfinde, sozusagen im Grunde genommen. Da muss ich irgendwie nicht mehr zu Hause irgendwie Aktenordner mit meinen Steuer bescheiden.
Stell dir einfach so was vor wie Urkundenversand. Das heißt, wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Kind geboren hast und dann musst du vielleicht nicht mehr auf Amt, sondern kannst du das eben so regeln, dass dir die Urkunde zu Geburt zugestellt wird. Und solche Dinge, die haben eine Menge Anwendungsszenarien. Da kann man sich glaube ich beliebig viel vorstellen.
Okay, aber das hört sich erstmal ganz gut an. Paul hat angerufen, das könnt ihr übrigens auch machen, unter 0331 77 97 110. Und Paul findet, um es kurz zusammenzufassen, das Ganze doof.
Ja, ihr habt ja einfach mal darum gebeten, dass man anruft und sagt, wie man das Ganze findet. Und ich denke, es ist eigentlich also erstmal überflüssig, weil ich hab jetzt, wenn ich eine E-Mail versende, gut, das sind jetzt keine Behörden, E-Mails, ich bin ja auch erst 16, da hab ich das eh noch nicht so viel, aber ich hab jetzt nicht so das Gefühl, dass die unsicher sind. Also ich denke jetzt nicht, wenn ich eine E-Mail abschicke, oh Gott, hoffentlich liest jetzt keiner mit und...
Ah, du meinst ja also unsicher im Sinne von, da könnte jemand mitlesen, ja?
Genau, bei den normalen E-Mails. Hab ich nicht so das Problem, also hab ich nicht die Sorge.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist ja nicht nur die Tatsache, dass jemand mitlesen könnte, also die Verschlüsselung ist eine Sache. Also es geht ja nicht nur darum, um den Inhalt, sondern geht ja auch darum, dass du zum Beispiel beweisen kannst, dass du das wirklich abgeschickt hast und auch ein Beweis hast, dass derjenige, der das kriegen soll, das wirklich bekommen hat. Das ist ja noch mal anders als nur den Inhalt.
Genau, das hab ich, nachdem ich angerufen hab, hab ich das dann auch gehört und hab gedacht, gut, das ist ein Grund und er hat ja dann auch gesagt, dass es nur für Behörden in erster Linie gedacht ist. Ich hab mich jetzt einfach mal zum Spaß, da haben wir so eine E-Mail-Adresse, oder bitte, De-Mail-Adresse reserviert.
Bei der Post ja?
Nee, bei GMX.
Ah, bei GMX. Sie haben ja nicht so viel Werbe-Halb gemacht, aber angefangen haben sie ja auch, ne? Wie heißt du da? Also, musst du den Nachnamen nicht sagen?
Da wurde dann auch gesagt, bitte geben sie ihren Namen so ein, wie er im Personalausweis steht und daraus wird dann eine De-Mail-Adresse generiert.
Hast du das gemacht? Okay, musstest du da schon irgendwie deine Identität nachweisen?
Nein, nur Adresse und Geburtsdatum, Staatsangehörigkeit, Geburtsort.
Das ist eine Vorregistrierung. Später wirst du das auch wirklich beweisen müssen. Hatte das übliche, also es gibt ja ein bestimmtes Format. Hattet das Format Vorname, Punkt, Nachname und eventuell mit einem Punkt dahinter noch eine Nummer?
Also genau, das ist so. Ich hab zwei Vornamen, da ist dann ein Unterstrich und dann ein Punkt und dann eine Nachname und dann dadurch, dass dieser Namenkombination, dass ich noch niemand bei GameX angemeldet hab, hat keine Zahl dahinter. Als mein zweiter Vorname noch nicht dabei war, war dann eine Eins dahinter.
Ja, da war schon einer, ja. Du konntest die Adresse wegen deines zweiten Vornames dann quasi ein bisschen aussuchen, richtig?
Genau, aber ich heiße mit Nachnamen Maya, das heißt, jetzt hab ich noch gesagt. Ich war eigentlich überrascht, dass ich dann nur die Eins dahinter musste, aber wahrscheinlich...
Und hinter dem Edge steht dann quasi gmx.de-mail.de... binde-strich-mail.de Das ist sozusagen immer der Aufbau, der für alle gelten wird, nur dass du der Anbietername dann jeweils... Genau. Aha, das heißt aber, dass du dann deine De-Mails auch tatsächlich mit deinem ganzen, also mit deinem vollen Namen quasi nicht jeder gibt, der immer so seinen Mittelnamen anverschenken wirst, richtig?
Super einfach zu merken auch. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit von Behörden geredet, ist es denn so, dass man auch sozusagen anderen De-Mail-Usern schreibt?
Ja klar, das ist klar.
Intern ist das ein vollständiges E-Mail-System, mehr oder weniger.
Ja, die Werbung ist auch durchaus so angelegt und auch die Begründung im Gesetzestext, dass auch Bürger zu Bürger, natürlich man hat ja auch Rechtsgeschäfte, die man also, die man echt privat macht. Und wenn du mal will in den privaten Autokauf, wird dir vielleicht den Kaufvertrag zuschicken, Witz oder sowas.
Und bei der Post habe ich in der Werbung auch gesehen, dass man irgendwie eine De-Mail oder E-Post, wie auch immer, an eine Adresse senden kann. Also eine richtige Adresse mit Straße und Postleiter. Und dass es dann ausgedrückt wird und dann im Briefkasten landet. Wobei ich da dann, jedenfalls wenn ich es privat mache, dann würde ich dann noch den Brief bevorzugen.
Ja, das ist nochmal so ein Unterprojekt. Darüber könnten wir auch nochmal reden.
Da kommen wir vielleicht auch nochmal drauf.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Also warum hast du dich registriert? Das war so ein bisschen der Punkt für dich.
Mein Gedanke war einfach nur, dass es ja sein könnte, dass das irgendwann ganz gut doch wirklich etabliert ist und dass es dann schick wäre, wenn man dann so eine Adresse hat, ohne irgendwelche kryptischen Zahlen, Kombinationen oder so. Wie es man ja mittlerweile bei E-Mails immer braucht.
Dass es ohne das klappt.
Das ist natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen so eine Wischiwaschi-Protivation, wenn ich es mal so nennen darf.
Aber die spannende Frage, die sich dann stellt, ist natürlich, alles was ich dazu gelesen habe, heißt, das ist freiwillig. Also es ist freiwillig sozusagen, damit zu machen, sich nicht, aber wenn ich jetzt wieder Paul eine De-Mail-Adresse habe, kann die Behörde dann sagen, so dann schicken wir das Zeug aber auch digital oder sagen hilft nur nicht anmelden, nicht dagegen.
Also nach dem Motto, ja jetzt hat Paul diese Adresse, man kann ja ihn quasi dazu zwingen, etwa den Steuer Bescheid dort entgegenzunehmen, das ist derzeit nicht vorgesehen, aber natürlich für eine zukünftige Entwicklung keineswegs ausgeschlossen, denn man muss sich immer überlegen, am Ende geht es natürlich um diese Papierlosigkeit, um Kostenersparnis und das wird vielleicht eher gar nicht mal eine Behörde machen, sondern eher ein Unternehmen, etwa eine Versicherung oder eine Bank, mit der du mit der du Geschäfte machst, vielleicht eher mal tun, aber zwingen können sie dich derzeit nicht, das ist auch nicht vorgesehen.
Ja, aber eine Firma kann halt immer sagen, sozusagen ich mache mit dir Geschäfte, aber nur wenn ich das per Mail mache.
Also für Firmen gilt das schon, also Unternehmer, die De-Mail anbieten, die selbst eine De-Mail-Adresse haben, die werden oder sollen per Gesetz verpflichtet werden, auf dieser Adresse auch Nachrichten anzunehmen. Also normale Privatbürger werden zumindest nach derzeitigem Stand nicht verpflichtet, auch in Zukunft nicht.
Also es ist nicht gesetzt, wir haben erst einen Wurf, aber den kann man sich ja schon mal ansehen, was da drin steht, denn es ist natürlich, wir haben jetzt das Beispiel von Paul, wo Name, Vorname, eventuell eine Nummer und dann eben der Anbieter und die E-Mail.de, dasselbe geht für juristische Personen. Also du kannst eben zum Beispiel einen Namen oder auch wie wir sagen, meiner Procura, Ed, Dachdecker Schulze, und dann De-Mail.de, das geht auch. Also es ist nicht nur für private Personen, sondern auch für juristische Personen.
Und die müssen das aber auch entgegennehmen, wenn es das gibt.
Richtig. So ist es jetzt erstmal vorgesehen.
Wenn sie das selbst benutzen, ja.
Paul, du hast ja jetzt diese Adresse dir geholt. Ich finde es ja cool, wenn du die Sendung bis zum Ende hörst und dann nochmal anrufst und sagst, ob du den Account behältst oder vielleicht doch...
Vielleicht wieder lösche.
Ja, genau, das kann ich nicht beweisen.
Also, bleib weiter dran, viel Spaß.
Ich kann euch noch kurz sagen, da wurden wie gesagt Namen wie im Personalausweis eintippen bitte. Und dann kommt einmal noch die Möglichkeit, sich weitere Wunschadressen dazu zu machen, die dann mit PN-Unterstrich anfangen für Pseudonym.
PN-Mausetarn-Ed, nicht schlecht.
Ja, das vorgesehene haben bisher glaube ich auch alle Anbieter. Das ist extra so vorgesehen, dass du natürlich vielleicht gegenüber Dritten mit einem Pseudonym auftrittst, aber man muss dich trotzdem ausweisen.
Aber gegenüber dem Anbieter, nicht gegenüber dem Dritten, dem ich ne Mail schreibe.
So sieht's aus.
Na Paul, dann bis nachher. So und dann haben wir noch den Christian. Der hat Anmerkungen oder Fragen zur Rechtssicherheit der De-Mail. Ja, los geht's.
Los geht's. Ja, ich finde es ja total doof. Da geht es schon mal los. Die E-Mail ist ja mal voll für ein Popo, weil das, was die gemacht haben, gibt es ja schon alles, das wird noch nicht benutzt. Und warum soll jetzt das benutzt werden?
Na dann sag uns mal, wie du das machst.
Also, ich selber mache das im Moment nicht so, aber ich habe mal in einer Firma gearbeitet, wo rechtssichere Geschäfte per E-Mail abgewickelt worden sind. Und zwar gab es da so einen Vertragsbrief, auf dem Fingerprints drauf standen. Und ich glaube, ihr wisst jetzt schon, wohin das geht. Ja, da wurde dann per Vertrag geregelt, E-Mails mit Signatur dessen Fingerprint sind als rechtsgültig anzusehen. Und dann wurde vereinbart, dass solche E-Mails der Empfang manuell bestätigt wird. Und somit war das rechtssichere Geschäft gemacht. Und ich weiß nicht, dazu braucht man die E-Mail nicht.
Wie bestätigt man den Empfang einer E-Mail manuell? Was genau meint das?
Hiermit bestätigen wir den Eingang ihrer E-Mail.
Also man schreibt eine Mail zurück?
Genau, man schreibt eine Mail zurück.
Hat nämlich auch gleich den Vorteil, dass der Empfänger weiß, die Mail ist beantwortet. Das ist noch viel besser, als zu wissen, die Mail ist im Postfach angekommen. Was bringt es mir zu wissen, die Mail ist im Postfach angekommen, wenn ich quasi den Empfänger dazu verpflichte, wenn er aber schon längst tot ist, dann kriege ich das wahrscheinlich erst mal drei Monate nicht mit. Wollen wir natürlich nicht hoffen, dass mein Empfänger tot ist, aber trotzdem...
Das ist ein interessantes Modell.
Über die Toten wird hier glaube ich nicht so viel gesagt.
War im Gesetzesentwurf nicht irgendetwas über gestorbene De-Mail-Besitzer? Nee, da haben wir glaube ich nichts. Dein Beispiel ist ja eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel. Das machen ja so einige Wirtschaftsunternehmen. Aber was, wenn deine ehemalige Firma mit einer Behörde kommunizieren will? Was ist dann? Also wenn deine ehemalige Firma nur mit einer Behörde kommunizieren wollte.
Dazu gibt es die Buchhaltung oder...
Ausdrucken.
Ja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es gibt einige Dinge, die möchte man vielleicht gar nicht so automatisiert haben, weil man sich vielleicht doch die ein oder andere Frist zurechtbiegen möchte.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch der Grund sein, warum das ganze Projekt scheitert.
Wir sollten das vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit mehr erwähnen. Wir wollen das nicht weiter im Detail aufdröseln. Wir wollten nur mal darauf hinweisen, dass natürlich diese De-Mail, insbesondere bei der Post unter dem alten Namen Gipost, auch schon Vorläuferprojekte hatte, sogar mehrere eigentlich. Und die sind alle glorios gescheitert. Einfach am Desinteresse der Leute, die sich da registrieren wollten.
Aber jetzt macht der immerhin schon Paul mit.
Ja, jetzt macht der immerhin schon Paul mit. Die haben mindestens einen Benutzer.
Es gibt andere Ansätze, die ich sinnvoller finde, um zwar nicht Papier zu sparen, aber um Transportkosten zu sparen. Und das ist die Post dort auszudrucken, wo sie zugestellt wird. Das finde ich einen viel interessanteren Ansatz, Kosten zu sparen, als das Ganze zu digitalisieren.
Das wird ja auch schon gemacht, das ist ja durchaus ein Service, was unsere deutsche Gelbe Post anbietet.
Nein, die druckt das aber zentral aus. Das spart nicht mal irgendwie Transportkosten, sondern es gibt ein zentrales Rechnen- und Druckzentrum, wo das ausgedruckt wird.
Wobei ich dann aber wieder die Frage stellen würde, wenn das ausgedruckt wird, dann kann ja derjenige, der es ausdruckt oder eintötet oder was auch immer, da besteht doch sozusagen sehr schnell die Gefahr, dass da noch Leute mitlesen, also noch mehr als bei E-Mails, wo man es zwar irgendwie automatisiert machen könnte oder halt in einem Brief. Wieso ist das dann praktisch?
Ja gut, das war natürlich ein Schnellschuss von mir. Natürlich kann es wieder jeder mitlesen. Die Bundesdruckerei ist auch ausgegliedert.
Ja, das stimmt überhaupt kein Argument.
Das müssen wir gleich mal aufklären. Die Bundesdruckerei ist zurückgekauft worden. Sie ist zwar eine private Firma, aber sie ist zurückgekauft worden aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Wow, hat da jemand Chaosradio gehört?
Wahrscheinlich.
Es ist tatsächlich so. Der damalige Innenminister hat noch begründet, dass es ein nationales Sicherheitsinteresse gäbe. Dann wurde die Firma zurückgekauft für einen symbolischen Preis. Ein Preis eben, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, aber zurück zu De-Mail. Ausdrucken haben wir jetzt gerade festgestellt, ist dann auch nicht so geil. Zumindest für Dinge, die dritte nichts angehen. Würdest du jetzt trotzdem die Finger davon lassen, Christian?
Also ich privat lass auf jeden Fall meine Finger davon. Weil ich mir nichts sagen lassen will, wann meine Post angekommen ist. Zumal ich, wenn ich jetzt eine Woche im Urlaub bin, und im Urlaub muss ich ganz ehrlich nicht im Internet sein, weil da hab ich andere Dinge zu tun, ich hab beruflich so viel damit zu tun, da ist auch mal eine Woche gut. Und wenn ich eine Klausel hab, dass ich einmal am Tag dieses Postfach checken muss, und diese Mail angekommen ist, und da diese Fristen gelten.
Jetzt sprichst du jemand an, was aber vor allen Dingen die Post in ihren AGB hat.
Und was nicht unbedingt legal sein muss.
Ja, das hat die Post so geregelt für ihren E-Postdreh.
Das hätte sie gern.
Aber ich dachte, das ist bald...
Richtig, und das unterzeichnest du auch, wenn du dich registrierst, dann stimmst du ja diesen AGB zu. Aber das ist nicht klar, ob die die anderen Anbieter auch so regeln. Da sollten wir vielleicht mal drüber reden.
Vielleicht sollten wir das aber machen nach den Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Okay. Christian, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Bleib dran. Vielleicht entscheidest du dich ja auch noch bis zur Endl-Sendung. Du wirst am Ende der Sendung ein total begeisterter Fan dann auf jeden Fall nochmal anrufen.
Ja gut, würde wahrscheinlich nicht passieren.
Wir werden uns noch nicht.
Vielleicht habt ihr noch ein paar gute Argumente dafür.
Oder ganz schlechte Gegend.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß noch. Und wir machen jetzt hier wie gesagt erstmal das Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht es gleich weiter. Und dann klären wir mal, wissen es jetzt, wenn eine De-Mail an mich geschickt wird, habe ich die dann auch quasi bekommen, ohne sie zu lesen.
Go.
Chaosradio ist heute, heute mit Constanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club und mit Jörg Pohle von der Humboldt Uni Berlin. Es geht um die De-Mail, also die neue, total sichere E-Mail, die vielleicht den Postbrief ablöst und alles total toll macht, vor allem die Bürokratie. Und wir hatten schon geklärt, was das ist, nämlich eine Mail, die halt genauso funktionieren soll. Also man kann sie zwischen Leuten hin und her schicken und es gilt dann wie ein Brief. Das wird über einen noch nicht näher geklärt, das technische System sichergestellt. Ob das funktioniert, müssen wir noch klären. Wir waren jetzt aber gerade bei der juristischen Seite und da kam immer wieder das Gerücht auf, wenn mir die Behörde eine Mail schickt und der Anbieter, bei dem ich die E-Mail habe, meldet der Behörde, okay die Mail ist bei mir angekommen, dann gilt sie im juristischen Sinne als zugestellt. Das heißt, ich habe quasi den Behördenbrief gelesen, heißt alle Fristen beginnen zu ticken, was doof ist, wenn ich gerade sechs Wochen in Spanien ist.
Erste Frage, ist es wirklich so, dass es nur ein Gerücht, nein, das ist so geplant, wobei das nicht gleich gelten soll, sondern nach drei Tagen.
Wie das heißt, also mein Anbieter meldet der Behörde, okay die Mail ist jetzt bei uns aufgeschlagen, die liegt im System, keine Ahnung, ob der Nutzer angeguckt hat, aber sie ist angekommen und dann sozusagen nach drei Tagen darf die Behörde davon ausgehen, okay der Bürger hat jetzt die Post zugestellt bekommen.
Es gibt da so ein bestimmtes Konzept, das nennt sich Machtbereich. Das kann man vergleichen mit dem Briefkasten. Das heißt, da gibt es sozusagen üblicherweise, hat man eben nach diesen drei Tagen in seinen Briefkasten geguckt. Da sind so Begriffe wie, da fällt es in die Macht desjenigen, der den Brief bekommt, weil ähnliches wollten Sie gern übertragen.
Genau und das haben sie extra eingefügt in das Verwaltungszustellungsgesetz. Sowas gibt es tatsächlich, das sind irgendwie absurde Sachen. Und dort steht drin, ein elektronisches Dokument gilt am dritten Tag nach der Absendung an das De-Mail-Postfach des Empfängers als seines hierfür eröffneten Zugangs als zugestellt.
Ist das auch so, wenn ich einen normalen Brief von der Behörde bekomme? Also sozusagen Analogbrief auf Papier, wenn die mir ihn schicken, ist das dann auch so?
Ja, der Vergleich hinkt leider ein bisschen. Man kann entweder einen normalen Brief nehmen oder einen einschreiben. Wenn ich einen einschreiben bekomme, gilt es natürlich nicht als zugestellt, wenn das bei der Poststelle ist, sondern erst dann, wenn ich ihn abhole. Und auch erst dann wird die Empfangsbestätigung rausgeschickt. Das heißt, wenn ich ihn nicht abhole, wenn ich zum Beispiel im Urlaub bin, wird es mir auch nicht als Empfang registriert. Da haben sie jetzt quasi technisch ein anderes System gebaut, nämlich zu sagen, es ist bei dem Anbieter in dem Portal vorhanden, unabhängig davon, ob er geht abrufen oder nicht. Das ist natürlich ein anderer Empfangsbegriff, als wir jetzt sonst etwa beim Einschreiben kennen. Bei einem normalen Brief ist es heute anders. Da sagt man schon, die Kenntnisnahme ist üblicherweise halt, wenn es in den Briefkasten eingeworfen ist, da rechnen die halt eine gewisse Frist dazu, die üblicherweise bei Briefen im Versand eben gebraucht wird.
Und wie ist das jetzt zu sagen, also ich komme jetzt nach sechs Wochen auf Spanien zurück, sehe, da liegt seit sechs Wochen ein Brief im Briefkasten. Also wir reden jetzt nochmal vom analogen Brief und dann ruft er bei der Behörde und sagt so, ey Leute, ich war einfach nicht da. Was passiert dann?
Da hast du die Fristen verpasst.
Normalerweise hast du die Fristen verpasst, aber es gibt dafür eigentlich eine Lösung, die heißt Wiedereinsetzung in den vorherigen Stand. Und das kannst du beantragen. Und normalerweise ist es so, dass wenn du einen guten Grund hast, warum du in den vergangenen Wochen nicht in deinen Briefkasten schauen konntest, dann wird das eigentlich auch immer gewährt. Und es ist selbst, dass sie zumindest das Bundesverfassungsgericht so, was durchaus dafür spricht, dass es sich durchgesetzt hat.
Heißt das, das wird bei De-Mail dann auch so sein? Also das heißt irgendwie, die Behörde hat zwar die Meldung vom Anbieter bekommen, okay, De-Mail liegt jetzt in seinem Postkasten, ich ruf mal sechs Wochen an und sag Leute, ich war im Urlaub.
Nein, das ist eben gerade bei De-Mail nicht vorgesehen. Denn die Zustellung ist, ja, es erfolgt, wenn es beim Anbieter angekommen ist. Und dann erfolgt auch die Bestätigung des Empfangs. Das ist wirklich ein anderes Konzept, was man mit dem Brief in Papierform so nicht vergleichen kann.
Es gilt im Prinzip sozusagen, wie ein abgeholtes Einschreiben ohne, dass ich es abgeholt habe.
Genau. Das ist natürlich auch ein Kritikpunkt, der jetzt hochkam. Wir sehen ja, dass an diesem De-Mail-Projekt generell, aber auch vor allen Dingen am E-Post-Brief jetzt, weil eben die Werbung läuft, eine Menge Kritik geübt wird. Aber ich glaube, ich sag da mal nicht so viel zu. Ich bin schon wieder vom Twitter angerannt, dass ich euch unterbreche. Der Twitter meckert mit mir, Entschuldigung.
Also generell gilt natürlich, wenn ihr irgendwas zu meckern habt, ihr könnt Konz auch gerne live bemeckern. Es geht hier. Jetzt anrufen. Ihr könnt euch aber auch gerne anrufen, wenn ihr Fragen oder Anmerkungen zum Thema habt.
Jetzt meckern mich bestimmt alle am Telefon an.
Aber wir werden jetzt gerade nochmal stehen geblieben bei dem Kritikpunkt. Das heißt also, es ist ja im Moment noch so, ich kriege Behördenpost per De-Mail nur, wenn ich mich da freiwillig anmelde. Das wäre für mich ja schon mal ein Grund zu sagen, ich fahre vielleicht öfter mal 6 Wochen Urlaub, ich möchte da nicht mitmachen. Das ist derzeit noch kein Problem.
Ja, aber es ist ja sowieso ein Konzept-Stadium derzeit. Dadurch, dass die Rechtssicherheit gesetzlich noch nicht geregelt ist und auch noch keine Rechtsverordnung nach dem Gesetz ergangen ist, ist es ja derzeit erstmal noch der Anmeld- und Registrierungsprozess. Du erhältst ja noch gar keine Behördenpost.
Das ist schon klar, aber wir reden ja heute darüber, ob das Konzept, wie es gerade besprochen wird, eine sinnvolle Sache ist. Und ich würde jetzt derzeit sagen, nee, da möchte ich nicht mitmachen, weil ich genau sowas gerne vermeiden möchte. Die andere Sache ist sozusagen, jede Mail, die ich verschicke, kostet Geld. Und zwar bei der Post genauso viel wie ein normaler Brief. Und dazu hat Christian eine Frage oder eine Anmerkung. Hallo Christian.
Ja, hi, eine Frage.
Na, sag mal.
Und zwar, ob jetzt schon irgendwie überhaupt was bekannt ist über Zahlungsmethoden.
Du meinst, wie das Geld zum De-Mail-Anbieter kommt?
Also es gibt ein paar Konzepte, die man dazu schon lesen kann. Das eine ist, diese ganzen Projekte, die haben einige Sachen, die eben optional sind und einige Sachen, die verpflichtend sind. Wir haben immer die optionalen Sachen noch nicht gesprochen. Dazu würde auch so ein Micropayment-Dienst, also eine Abrechung des Dements, zählen. Das ist halt nicht unbedingt drin, muss man nicht machen als Anbieter. Aber die meisten werden es wohl tun. Und einige haben es auch schon angekündigt. Allerdings ist es diese Micropayment und noch nicht umgesetzt, dass man es jetzt betrachten könnte. Bei der Post, bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, wie sie da die Bezahlung machen. Weißt du dazu vielleicht, Jörg?
Die haben da auch irgendwie, da muss man sich anmelden und dann ist das, als würde man dort bei denen ein Konto führen.
Weil die Postbank mit angebildet ist, oder?
Das kann durchaus sein.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß, dass es Micropayment-Abrechungssysteme gibt, die geplant sind, damit sind auch schon einige Unternehmen, jenseits der Post, also andere Unternehmen, an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen. Aber bei der Post weiß ich es zum Beispiel nicht. Also kann ich nicht mit Sicherheit sagen.
Ah, ein Guthabenkonto gibt es bei der Post.
Wissen wir also noch nicht so genau. Also wir sehen Konzept statt.
Also die spannende Frage, die sich mir da stellt, ist, es ist ja oft, wenn es um solche Sachen geht, wird ja die Datenschutzfrage wieder gestellt, weil inwiefern ist aus der Bezahlung eines Dienstes dann wiederum, wird da wieder eine weitere Datenspur gelegt oder ist daraus ersehbar? Gibt es also eine Art und Weise, wie ich in Zukunft die E-Mail anonym bezahlen kann? Also keine Ahnung, wie gut Hademkarten ich im Supermarkt kaufe oder ist das?
Das macht aber konzeptuell gar keinen Sinn, denn wenn das erstmal in der Form, wie es im Gesetz vorgesehen ist, ausgerollt ist, dann musst du dich ohnehin sicher ausweisen. Egal auf welchem Wege, ob du das später mal etwa mit deinem elektronischen Personalausweis tust oder ob du zur Post gehen musst und dieses Post-Ident-Verfahren durchführen musst oder auch bei einem anderen Bieter wird es eine sichere Form der Ausweisung geben. Das heißt, es ist immer genau rückschließbar, welche Person steckt dahinter. Das ist ja gerade Teil des Konzeptes.
Achso, das meinte ich jetzt gar nicht. Ich meinte eher so was wie, wenn es nur per Lastschriftverfahren geht, dann weiß meine Bank auch immer, wann ich einen Brief schreibe und das will ich ja vielleicht gar nicht.
Also du meinst für Einzelabrechnung.
Genau.
Achso, aber wenn das Guthabenkonto heißt, dann kannst du sowieso dann einen Brief schicken, wenn da Geld drauf liegt.
Aber dieses Micro-Payment, was eben angekündigt wurde, könnte schon dazu führen, dass man nicht unbedingt ein Guthabenkonto hat, sondern eben einzeln bezahlt. Wir wünschen uns ja in vielen Bereichen manchmal, dass es funktionierende Micro-Payment-Systeme gibt, aber da müssen wir wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen drauf warten. Da können wir gespannt sein. Aber es gibt, wo wir dabei sind, es gibt natürlich noch andere optionale Dienste, die wir noch nicht mal erwähnt haben. Wie soll man mich das mal ansprechen?
Bevor wir das machen, Christian, hast du noch eine Frage?
Oh ja, Christian, Entschuldigung.
Nee, immer redet.
Na okay, das machen wir gerne, aber dazu müssen wir dich ja nicht in der Leitung halten. Wie sieht es denn bei dir aus? Wie ist bei dir der aktuelle Stand? Würdest du dir das holen oder eher nicht?
Ach, das war jetzt eigentlich bloß aus Null. Hier so im Großen und Ganzen interessiert mich nicht groß. Aber da hat jetzt eben gerade was zu hören geturkt. Mir geht es gerne an. Mir ging es eher darum, wie könnte man bezahlen, da ich meine Daten, gerade meine Kontedaten, nie irgendwie im Internet anhebe. Wäre für mich eher so ein Lastschneller-Verfahren über Bank irgendwie interessant. Aber wenn irgendwer mal kommt, vielleicht holt man sich das mal, weil praktisch nachher ist. Aber ansonsten war das jetzt eigentlich bloß aus Null.
Wie ist denn das jetzt bei dir? Also ein Anbieter ist ja die Telekom. Also die Telekom wird ja einer dieser sogenannten Bürgerportal-Dienstanbieter sein. Es steht ja auch schon fest, spielt für dich eine Überlegung eine Rolle, dass die Telekom ja in der Vergangenheit mit ziemlich, ja mit einem riesengroßen Datenskandal verknüpft war. Spielt das was eine Rolle für dich bei so einer Überlegung?
Also eigentlich hat ja sowieso jeder meine Daten, da sie irgendwie immer weiter verkauft werden. Aber nun muss ich das nicht noch irgendwie mitfördern und die Daten überall annehmen. Wenn ich das auf Papier wegen irgendwie mache oder in einem Vertrag dann eben festhalte, ist das für mich irgendwie immer noch anders, als wenn ich das denn so frei in Internet einnehme.
Aber der einzelne Anbieter und seine Reputation spielen da bei dir eh eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Ich glaube, selbst wenn da nichts bekannt ist, ist da immer irgendwie Datenklau.
Alles klar, also wenn sich Christian was holt, was er noch nicht genau weiß, dann egal, bei welchem Anbieter. Wir kommen jetzt zu den optionalen Zusatzdiensten. Es ist jetzt schon ein paar Mal hier gefallen, also sagen, wenn Anbieter die E-Mail anbieten, müssen sie auf jeden Fall ein Webinterface anbieten. Sie müssen zusichern, dass die Mail ankommt. Und dass das irgendwie mit über...
Und der Inhalt nicht verändert wurde?
Genau, und über Verschlüsselung müsste man eigentlich auch noch mal reden. Aber jetzt gibt es noch Zusatzdienste.
Genau, und dann sind neben diesem Micropayment, was noch ein bisschen unklar ist, haben wir eben schon darüber gesprochen, auch ein sogenannter Dateientresor, ein Dokumentenspeicher, der heißt in Neudeutsch.de safe. Also die haben ja für alle diese Begriffe, seltsame neudeutsche Worte gefunden. Also es ist ein Dokumentenspeicher, der in der Testregion in Friedrichshafen 100 Megabyte umfasst hat. Also war nach der Akzeptanzstudie den Test dann wohl ein bisschen klein, aber man soll gleichzeitig eine Art Tresor haben, ein Safe, wo man Dokumente sicher verwahren kann. Da ist natürlich auch einiges strittig, ob man es so machen kann. Und der zweite, was zu den optionalen Diensten dazugehört, wo wir auch davon ausgehen, dass dort viele Anbieter machen werden, ist eine elektronische Identitätsnachweis. Der hat auch so einen neudeutschen Namen bekommen, der heißt jetzt eIdent.
Hä?
Also beide Dienste sollen angeboten werden. Also was Ähnliches, was eben jetzt auf dem neuen elektronischen Personalausweis enthalten sein wird, also eine virtuelle Identität, wo man sich zum Beispiel neben mal Filme ausleihen, also was weiß ich nicht, nicht jugendfreie Angebote, die über 18 sind, dann kann man halt zum Beispiel damit nachweisen, welches Alter man hat oder eben auch einen Vertrag abschließen, sowas in der Art.
Also quasi das Händler dann sagen, weiß mal bitte hier nach, dass die Adresse, wo du gerade eben bestellst, auch tatsächlich am Start ist. Du hast jetzt gerade irgendwie den E-Pass, wie heißt der? N-Pass?
L-Pass? Ja, jetzt heißt er, die haben wir ein paar Mal umgebracht, jetzt heißt er wohl N-PA für...
Neuer Personalausweis.
Neuer, ganz total original. Früher hieß er E-PA. Wir können ihn nur einfach mal Ausweis nennen.
Also okay, der elektronische Ausweis, der irgendwie später mal kommen soll?
Am 1. November diesen Jahres.
Ach, bis wann muss man seinen Ausweis verlieren, wenn man noch einen alten will?
Ja, wir empfehlen es sowieso jedem. Man soll sich möglichst doch bis Ende September...
Es gibt doch einen Stichtag.
Ja, das ist nicht mal nicht so ganz klar. September ist ein sicherer Datum, dass man nicht einen neuen bekommt. Man spart eine Menge Geld und spart sich...
So Portemonnaies kommen ja auch weg. Häufiger mal, wo so Ausweise drin sind.
Na und der Hund.
Okay, gut, dass wir das geklärt haben. Zurück zur De-Mail. Gibt es jetzt eine Verbindung zwischen dem elektronischen Personalausweis und der De-Mail oder?
Kann man schon sagen, dass es den gibt. Denn in den ganzen, in den Gruppkonzepten ist natürlich angegeben, dass man später die Identifizierung, also der sichere Nachweis, dass man der ist, der sich da registriert, über den elektronischen Personalausweis machen kann. Das ist natürlich alles schon vorgesehen. Das gehört schon zu der langfristigen Strategie, die da verfolgt wird.
Wie ist denn das derzeit, wenn ich mich gerade bei so einem... Oder wie ist das derzeit geplant?
Ich geh zur Post, ich muss da physisch erscheinen.
Genau, ein Postident, also das einzige, was tatsächlich wirklich weit verbreitet ist, ist Postident.
Das heißt, ich geh zur Post, zeig meinen Ausweis vor und...
Genau, oder einen anderen Ausweis, einen anderen Ausweis und dann...
Es gibt ähnliche Verfahren, die von anderen Anbietern, wie UPS oder FedEx angeboten werden, die eben so was sicherstellen. Das wird ja schon lange gebraucht, deswegen wird es natürlich so ein Services-Angebot.
Aber es geht immer darum, dass ich irgendwo persönlich erscheine und meinen Ausweis dabei habe.
Das ist tatsächlich ein mehrstufiger Prozess. Heute, wenn du den e-Postbrief beantragst, natürlich auch noch was ausdrucken und hinschicken. Also heute ist das nicht so einfach. Aber in Zukunft erhofft man sich natürlich da durch den elektronischen Personalausweis mehr. Auch da sind wir natürlich enorm skeptisch.
Alles wird viel einfacher und Biene findet es glaube ich super. Hallo Biene.
Es tut uns leid, dass du so lange warten musstest, aber die Leitungen sind so voll.
Und du würdest dir eine De-Mail-Adresse holen oder nicht?
Weil ich sag mal so an sich ist es eine ganz gute Idee. Sprich wegen dem Papier und so, die ganzen Bäume und sowas. Nee, aber das andere ist, was mache ich nur, wenn ich ein Virus auf mein Computer kriege, dann sind die ganzen gespeicherten Blätter, Daten und das wichtige Dokumente weg, kann ich sie nicht wiederholen.
Na, du hast also eher so ein bisschen IT-Security-Bedenken, so da könnte irgendwas schiefgehen. Da sind also deine Befürchtungen, ja? Also natürlich gibt es da so ein paar Angriffspunkte, die man eigentlich schon konzeptuell in dem System sehen kann. Das betrifft vor allen Dingen diesen sogenannten Dokumenten. Jetzt, liebe Hörer, kommen wir zum spannenden Teil. Ist vor allen Dingen dieser DE-Safe. Da kann man natürlich eine Menge dran kritisieren. Wenn man sich überlegt, dass also an einer zentralen Stelle bei einem Anbieter diese Dokumente hinterlegt werden, dann fragt man sich natürlich, wer hat da Zugriff? Wie sind die Konzepte? Wenn man es mal vergleicht mit einem typischen klassischen Tresor, den man bei einer Bank hat, so ist der Zugang zu diesem Tresor in besonderer Weise geregelt. Nicht so bei dem Bürgerportalanbietern. Wenn die also so einen digitalen Dokumentenspeicher haben, wo man seine Behördenpost und so weiter hinterlegen kann, dann ist der quasi im Netz erreichbar und an einer bestimmten Adresse, die auch gelistet ist. Denn die Anbieter sind ja alle registriert und zertifiziert dann später. Und das ist, als wenn man einen Banksafe auf einem Bürgersteig platziert und darauf wartet, wer den eventuell angreift. Und was passiert, wenn die Kunden ihren Schlüssel vergessen? Das passiert, Menschen sind Menschen. Also muss man sich überlegen, ob es Nachschlüsse gibt. Wer hat diese Nachschlüsse? Also wer kann verhindern, dass ein vergessenes Passwort eine nicht-zugreifbare Zugreifbarkeit dieser Dokumente zur Folge hat? Also muss es Nachschlüsse geben? Also was macht man, wenn man die Schlüsse wieder neu generieren muss? Braucht man also Nachschlüsse? Wer hat die? Wer darf darauf zugreifen? Nur der Anbieter? Auch vielleicht Strafverfolgungsbehörden?
Da hab ich ja einen Blogartikel gelesen, wo man das System auseinandergenommen hat und zum Schluss gekommen ist. Also eigentlich so derzeitige Gesetzeslage darf da jeder reingucken. Oder mit relativ geringem Aufwand. Jeder im Sinne von jeder Behörde, jeder Institution.
Wie sieht es da aus? Na ja, wenn du Rechte hast, dann verbrauchst du teilweise eine Richtergenehmigung. Das ist dann eine Herausgabe oder Beschlagnahme. Natürlich, das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Sache, als wenn ich meine Dokumente auf meiner eigenen Platte habe. Dann bin ich für die Sicherheit dieser Platte selber zuständig. Und wenn ich das an jemanden auslagere, also ein Anbieter, dann gibt es natürlich für diese dahinterlegten Dokumente auch eine Möglichkeit des Zugriffs. Denn die sind ja nicht unter meiner Herrschaft und den Schlüssel habe nicht nur ich. Da ist natürlich für die Beschlagnahme nicht nur unbedingt Strafverfolgungsbehörden, sondern geht natürlich auch um private Leute, die ein Interesse haben. Wir reden manchmal mal über Urheberrechtsverletzungen, wo die Anwälte Herausgaben verlangen oder so. Auch da können in diesem Wege Forderungen zur Herausgabe der Schlüssel durchaus passieren.
Das wäre für mich persönlich das zweite Argument, dagegen diesen Dienst mitzumachen, weil ich nicht so gerne möchte, dass beliebig viele Leute meine privaten Akten durchstöbern können. Bine, wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Außerdenen gibt es ja dann noch diese schönen Hacker oder Maulsauce. Und die können ja am dritten weiter reichen und da kommt man dann sehr in Schwierigkeiten oder da sind irgendwelche polizeilichen Akten dabei und die kriegt dann irgendwie der Chef zugespielt und ja.
Also im Großen und Ganzen sagen fährst du die Stimme, dass du sagst, das ist ja einfach zu krass, das ganze Ding in digitaler Form abzulegen, weil dann sozusagen in deinen Augen es einfach viel einfacher ist, dass die Sachen wegkommen. Das stimmt natürlich, ein interessanter Punkt. Biene, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und viel Spaß weiterhin mit den Papierbriefen.
Man kann sich da eine ganze Menge Sachen überlegen, die da interessant sind. Man muss auch nicht immer vielleicht an den privaten Bereich denken. Man muss auch mal an Wirtschaftsspionage denken. Denn hier geht es ja vor allen Dingen um Briefe, die juristischen Belang haben, also die in irgendeiner Form Rechtsfolgen zeitigen. Also ist natürlich, wenn man an einer zentralen Stelle so einen Dokumenten-Server aufsetzt oder ebenfalls attraktive Papiere auflegt, auch die Wirtschaftsspionage nicht weit. Und man muss immer überlegen, dieser Dokumenten-Server steht auf einem Netz, also wo er ist, ist erstmal klar. Da wird natürlich jeder Attacke attraktiv. Eigentlich glaube ich mal so ein bisschen unter Sicherheits-Sichtpunkten, da muss man schon in die Stirn runzeln. Die Anbieter sind ja registriert, das ist schon klar.
Ich glaube wir müssen jetzt mal einen kurzen Moment sammeln und dann müssen wir mal ganz ausführlich über Sicherheit reden, weil da spielt ja auch Verschlüsselung eine Rolle, da spielt wie gesagt die Aufbewahrung der Dokumente eine Rolle, da spielt im Prinzip auch eine Rolle, wie vertrauenswürdig der einzelne Anbieter ist, also ob man dem überhaupt in der Lage hält, so eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Das machen wir alles gleich, wir gönnen uns aber eine kurze Sprechpause und die gönnen wir uns mit Professor Klicks All Control im Harder Than Hard Mix. Die zwei Sprechstunden heute Chaos Radio mit Markus Richter, Konstanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club und Jörg Pohle von der Humboldt Uni Berlin und es geht um die De-Mail, also diese ganz neue E-Mail Form, die einen Brief ersetzen soll und total sicher sein soll. Die Behörden schicken uns dann darüber die Posten. Es wird alles viel, viel einfacher. Im Laufe der Sendung sind schon zwei Gründe für mich persönlich zumindest zusammengekommen, wo ich sage, ich möchte lieber nicht mitmachen, weil einerseits ist es so, wenn euch Behörden über dieses System einen Brief schicken, ist angedacht, dass es so sein soll, wenn drei Tage vergangen sind und der Anbieter dieser De-Mail gesagt hat der Behörde, okay der Brief ist angekommen, dann gilt er quasi als gelesen, was natürlich nicht so prall ist und dann gibt es so, dass die Daten liegen ja dann auf einem Rechner rum. Es gibt auch ein Zusatzangebot, den sogenannten DE-Save und da gibt es also jede Menge offizieller Institutionen, die relativ einfach Zugriff auf meine Dokumente haben, was ich persönlich nicht so prall finde. Aber das könnt ihr ja vielleicht anders sehen. Wenn ihr das anders seht, dann könnt ihr hier anrufen. Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Oder wenn ihr es genauso seht, also wenn ihr eine Meinung zu dem Thema habt auf jeden Fall. Und Herr Reinhardt hat noch angerufen. Hallo und guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend.
Du hattest noch eine Frage?
Ja, leider seid ihr schon mit dem Thema ein bisschen weiter gerückt.
Macht ihr nichts.
Und zwar mit der, mit der, mit der Behörde, dass zugestellt worden ist. Wir haben festgestellt, dass GMX E-Mails filtert und die andere Sache war, dass E-Mails, obwohl sie selber persönlich manuell nicht als Spam eingesortiert waren, dass nachher E-Mail im Spam bei mir lag, in einem Postfach.
Okay, aber dann sagen, ich glaube, das geht ganz schnell. Also wird ja bei De-Mail, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, nicht so sein, dass das ein normales Mailsystem ist?
Nein, und wenn die einfach so E-Mails rausfiltern, dann gibt es, also die E-Mails rausfiltern, dann gäbe es, glaube ich, auch tierischen Ärger.
Also rechtlichen Ärger.
Rechtlichen Ärger und die könnten die die Zuleistung verlieren.
Also sollte man vielleicht nicht vergleichen, das Gratis-Mailsystem, was GMX fährt oder Web.de fährt oder andere Anbieter und diese Bezahl-Mails. Warum man einen griffigen Begriff dafür finden, Bezahl-Mails, finde ich merkwürdig.
Bezahl-Mails ist super.
Also das kann man, glaube ich, nicht vergleichen, das werden sie auch sicherlich technisch trennen müssen, denn die Anforderungen, wenn sie sich zertifizieren lassen, für diese De-Mails sind hoch. Sie müssen sich überhaupt zertifizieren lassen, das werden sie auch technisch trennen.
Naja, aber wir garantieren, dass sie nicht trotzdem gefiltert werden. Das ist ja intern beim Provider, beim Anbieter. Die haben ja die Technik und die Technik überprüft ja keiner, wie die eingestellt ist.
Meinst du jetzt gerade Spam-Filter oder meinst du andere Filter?
Andere Filter, Spam-Filter bzw. auch andere Filter.
Spam-Filter in der Form, wie du sie vom Freemail-Anbieter kennst, wird es nicht geben?
Das sagt Markus jetzt so. Diese Spam-Problematik, die wollten wir eigentlich eh noch ansprechen.
Moment, in diesem System sind doch nur juristische oder private Personen oder Behörden, die nachgewiesen haben, dass sie sozusagen Mails verschicken dürfen und da kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass sie keinen Spam verschicken.
Naja, der Absender ist ein Computer.
Ne, also das muss man schon mal sehr klar sagen. Denn die Adressformate, die wir vorhin genannt haben, die sind vorkonfiguriert. Die lauten immer in derselben Form Vorname Punkt, Nachname Punkt und wenn mehrere Leute gibt dann noch einen Punkt mit einer Nummer dahinter. Also eine Nummerierung der Person. Danach kommt immer ein Etat et Zeichen. Der Anbietername, wir nehmen mal GMX, dann ein Punkt, dann de-strich mehr de. Das heißt, die sind insofern generisch. Das heißt, wir wissen folgendes. Welche Anbieter gibt es? Die sind öffentlich. Die kann man also, die sogenannten Bürgerportals, Dienstanbieter, die sind öffentlich. Die kann ich mir suchen. Und ich kann Teilnehmer, von denen ich Vor- und Zunahme habe, also normale Adresslisten oder Telefonbücher, kann ich mir hernehmen. Damit habe ich generierbare Adressen.
Aber was habe ich denn davon? Weil ihr habt doch vorhin erklärt, ich kann gar keine Medien in das System reinstecken, wenn ich nicht sozusagen auch ein zertifizierter Absender bin.
Und wenn du dich selber registrierst?
Wie selber?
Also das ist ja eine Möglichkeit. Also du kannst ja selber eine De-Mail-Adresse haben.
Oder du könntest die De-Mail-Adresse von jemand anderem benutzen.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich sehr einfach, hier eine valide Adressliste zu haben für Spammer. Das heißt, die Argumentation, dieses ganze System würde gegen Spam helfen, ist doch ausgesprochen fragwürdig. Aber wir haben noch was Lustiges entdeckt, was dem eventuell entgegenwirken könnte. Nämlich, man kann maximal 100 Nachrichten am Tag versenden. Da mussten wir doch lachen drüber.
Und maximal an 300 Leute.
Insofern haben sie eine physische Grenze eingebaut.
Man kann also nicht so viel Spam kriegen.
Ich meine, Spam ist Spam. Soll ich mir nachher noch die Zeit nehmen, denn da auch noch zu sortieren? Beziehungsweise, wer garantiert mir denn, dass die Sachen vom Anbieter nicht auch irgendwie, nicht von mir eingestellt, irgendwie nicht weitergeleitet werden? Oder sind, ohne dass ich das in meinen eigenen Spamfilter gelegt hab, dort abgelegt werden? Und wie ihr sagt, bleiben wir bitte bei der Bestätigung. Die sind eingegangen. Die sind eingegangen. Drei Tage. Ich weiß das nicht. Und meine Fristen laufen.
Naja, also ich seh schon ein, was du von Punkt machen willst. Aber da ist der Anbieter, ich sag mal von der juristischen Seite, natürlich verpflichtet. Das heißt, er würde sich da klar gegen das Gesetz oder gegen die Rechtsverordnung wenden. Das heißt, er hat dann Pflichten, die hat er zu erfüllen. Er kann nicht irgendwas wegfiltern.
Also um es genau zu sagen, am Anfang wurde erklärt, der Anbieter meldet ja an den Absender der De-Mail, die Mail ist bei uns angekommen und liegt jetzt theoretisch beim Nutzer am Postkasten. Das heißt, wenn die Mail im Spam…
Auf Verlangen des Absenders. Also nicht in jedem Fall.
Ach, macht das nicht immer? Genau.
Aber das ist dann auch eine Garantie.
Genau, aber wenn diese Meldung gekommen ist, dann muss sie also sagen, im Briefkasten, also in der Inbox des Empfängers liegen und darf nicht irgendwie in einem Spamfach oder wir stellen dir das vielleicht zu.
Also die Postfach, diese E-Mail hat keine Spam-Unterordner?
Hat es möglicherweise, aber wenn darin eine Mail liegt, zählt das nicht als Laufzeit. Also es zählt erst als eingegangen, wenn es bei dir in der Inbox geht. Also so ist das Konzept.
Naja, wir können nicht sagen, ob tatsächlich ein Spam-Orner angelegt wird. Da es bisher kein System gibt, wo man sich das mal ansehen könnte. Ich halte es für unwahrscheinlich, dass sie, wie bei den Gratismails, bei den Bezahl-Mails auch, einen Spam-Orner überhaupt anlegen. Das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen. Denn da würden sie, es wird vielleicht später mal irgendwann kommen, wenn es sich herausstellt, dass es wirklich Spam gibt, aber am Anfang werden sie sicherlich ihr eigenes Konzept negieren, wenn sie das überhaupt tun. Dennoch ist natürlich vom Aufbau her, der ja wirklich sehr generisch ist, klar, dass diese Adressen sehr einfach zu generieren sind von Spamern. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen lustig, dass die Post jetzt betont, man könnte damit angeblich beim Bekämpfen.
Rainer, beantwortet das jetzt deine Frage?
Nicht so zufriedenstellend, aber das war das. Also auf alle Fälle, ich werde mir keine E-Brief im Postfach zulegen, weil es mir einfach zu unsicher, beziehungsweise noch mehr Daten für einen Staat, die Elenora oder wie das heißt, Plus-E-Brief muss nicht sein. Das war's.
Alles klar. Also Rainer auch dagegen. Ich glaube, es steht jetzt 5 zu 0 oder so.
4 zu 0, ja.
Hörer gegen De-Mail. Falls es draus jemanden gibt, der findet, die De-Mail-Superidee muss ich unbedingt haben. Herzlich willkommen an die Handrufe 0331 70 97 110. Vielleicht gibt es ja ganz gute Gründe, warum das alles total toll ist. Wir haben es einfach noch nicht quasi entdeckt.
Das ist aber ganz schlecht. Auf unserer Liste sind nur Gegengründe noch, die wir noch nennen wollen.
Deswegen sollen ja Leute anrufen, weil möglicherweise habt ihr was übersehen.
Vielleicht seid ihr einfach immer so böse Kritiker, die an nichts was guten lassen.
Wir haben am Anfang ja die Idee, die jetzt hinter dem Konzept steht, die haben wir ja eigentlich schon erstmal nicht so negativ dargestellt.
Das ist also die Umsetzung, die bemängelt wird.
Ja, da können wir das glaube ich zusammenfassen, oder?
Ja, durchaus. Allerdings weiß man auch nicht so genau, was die Idee ist, weil einerseits wird damit Werbung gemacht, dass man dort den Brief, wie wir den aus der Realwelt kennen, ins Netz bringt. Und andererseits wird damit Werbung gemacht, dass es einfach nur die Vorteile der E-Mail zusammengeführt mit Sicherheit und Datenschutz sei. Das ist aber sehr unterschiedlich. Insofern herrschen da offensichtlich auch viele Unklarheiten. Und die Tatsache, dass dort sich die Projekte immer wieder umbenennen und immer mal wieder neue Namen bekommen, spricht auch nicht gerade dafür, dass da jemand wirklich nachgedacht hat.
Okay, ich würde jetzt gerne noch mal zu einer ganz grundsätzlichen Sache kommen, die sich bei dieser De-Mail ja stellt, und zwar die technische Umsetzung von Verschlüsselung und Signatur. Also es soll ja so sein, dass einerseits sichergestellt wird, dass der Inhalt, der in dieser Mail steht, während des Sende- oder Versendungsvorgangs nicht verändert werden kann. Das heißt also der Empfänger soll sicher sein können, das was da drin steht, hat der Absender genauso geschrieben. Und dann soll es ja auch verschlüsselt sein. Also sagen, da darf zwischendurch, also jetzt mal irgendwie, wenn es zumindest nicht, wenn es um Behörden geht oder sowas, darf eigentlich keiner reingucken. Wie, also erstmal Signatur, wie wird das gemacht? Und wie zuverlässig ist das?
Im Gegensatz zu dem was man sonst so kennt, sowas wie GNU PG oder PGP, wird die Signatur nicht auf dem Rechner des, also die Signatur, die dort eingesetzt wird, nicht auf dem Rechner des Absenders berechnet. Sondern auf dem Server des Diensteanbieters.
Sollten wir vielleicht mal ganz allgemein sagen, was eine Signatur praktisch bedeutet, was man eigentlich tut.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade fragen.
Genau, das ist ja ein einfacher Konzept. Was man tut, ist, man berechnet einen mathematischen Wert, also eine Zahl über den Inhalt dieser E-Mail. Das heißt, man versucht mit dieser Zahl nachher abzugleichen, einmal beim Sender und beim Empfänger, ob sich der Inhalt verändert hat. Und man nimmt diese sogenannte Check-Summe, einen Hash-Wert, also eine bestimmte Zahl, und guckt, ob die sich nicht ändert. Das heißt, man hat einen mathematischen Verfahren, mit dem man die gesamte E-Mail betrachtet, daraus bildet man diesen Wert, und der darf sich halt nicht verändern. Denn die kleinste Veränderung am Inhalt der Mail würde diese Zahl verändern. Das ist eigentlich ein mathematisch günstiger Verfahren, das ist eine sogenannte Einwegfunktion. Das heißt, durchzuführen ist ja einfach. Bei den normalen Mails ist das im Prinzip nur noch ein Knopf oder eine kleine Berechnung jedenfalls, dauert nicht lange. Und aber derjenige, der die bekommt, kann damit auf leichtem Wege checken, hat sich da was verändert oder ist dieser Hash-Wert, also diese Check-Summe, gleichgeblieben. Das ist ungefähr, wenn man es jetzt mal ganz untechnisch ausdrücken will, so ungefähr der Weg.
Und das ist bei den Systemen, die derzeit eingesetzt werden, so, dass das auf meinem Rechner passiert, wenn ich die Mail schreibe?
Ja, ich benutze sowas seit etwa, ich weiß nicht, einer Dekade sogar. Ich glaube 15 Jahre gibt es das schon für E-Mails. Der Punkt ist nicht, das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Ich glaube der Punkt ist dran, dass es natürlich dafür sehr lange Verfahren gibt, die gut funktionieren, die open source sind, die doch nicht so kleiner Anteil benutzt. Also bei meinen Studenten etwa sind das gut 20% die solche Verfahren benutzen und die nicht nur signieren, sondern in der Inhalt verschlüsseln. Das ist ein kombiniertes Programm. In dem Fall GNU-PG und in der Bezahlvariante PGP. Die man sich downloaden kann für viele Clients. Sondern ist am Ende die Verstößung und Signierung für viele E-Mail Benutzer normal geworden. Also das heißt, das ist seit vielen Jahren bekannt. Das ist ein kostenloses Verfahren. Und für gerade so die technische Community schätze ich da die Frage, warum sollten wir das überhaupt benutzen? Wir haben sowas seit langem. Wir können E-Mails signieren und verstößen. Und zwar unter unserer Herrschaft. Wir haben die Schlüssel. Nicht irgendein Dritter signiert auf irgendeinem Rechner.
Aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen der Nachteil dran? Dass das nicht direkt bei mir passiert, sondern auf dem Anbieter. Der wird sozusagen die Verbindung von mir zu Hause zu seinem Webportal bestimmt verschlüsseln und macht das dann irgendwie, wirft da Mathe-Voodoo drauf, damit das irgendwie bei der Übertragung funktioniert. Was ist denn der Nachteil für mich als User?
Also, dass die Verbindung zwischen dir und dem Anbieter oder seinem Web-Server verschlüsselt ist, sorgt nur dafür, dass Leute, die außerhalb sitzen, diese Nachrichten nicht lesen können. Aber dein Anbieter kann das schonen. Und er kann die Nachricht eigentlich auch ändern, bevor er sie weiterleitet. Also es gibt keine Garantie. Das ist eigentlich eine simulierte Sicherheit, was dahinter steht.
Wir wollen mal vielleicht mit dem normalen Papierbrief vergleichen. Das ist also im Prinzip als wenn der Anbieter den Umschlag öffnet, einen neuen Umschlag darum macht und den Brief weiter sendet. Also es gibt einen kurzen Moment, also in Digitalien ist es natürlich ein ganz kurzer Moment, wo sie eben den Brief kurz öffnen. So kann man das vergleichen. Das würden wir im Bereich der Papierpost als inakzeptabel finden.
Das ist ja dann, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, beim Empfänger dann genauso. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass der Empfänger den Brief auspackt, sondern der Anbieter, bei dem der Empfänger ist, der packt den Brief aus und sagt dann hier guck mal Empfänger, so sieht der Brief aus.
Der packt den auf dem Server aus und das was er dem Empfänger dann anzeigt ist der Brief selbst und dass die Signatur in Ordnung ist.
Das heißt also ich hab pro Sendevorgang zwei eigentlich nicht beteiligte Parteien, also vielleicht wenn es der selber anbietet ist nur einer, aber im Prinzip zwei nicht beteiligte Parteien, die einen Blick in die Kommunikation haben. Hat das juristische irgendwelche Konsequenzen oder ist es im Konzept derzeit nicht vorgesehen, dass das Konsequenzen hat? Also da könnte man ja sagen, wenn da Dritte dran sein können und das bei jedem Vorgang auch sind, dann ist es halt doch nicht so ganz sicher.
Na da wird natürlich wieder mal die legalistische Schiene gefahren, zu sagen, also der Anbieter ist natürlich von vorne rein im ganzen Konzept vertrauensvoll, denn er ist ja zertifiziert, er hält sich also an die Regeln und insofern wäre von der juristischen Seite natürlich kein Problem. Der Anbieter ist ja Teil dieses Konzepts. Er ist der Bürgerportaldienstanbieter, muss sich zertifizieren und ist damit einer von den guten TM.
Wie, diese Zertifizierung, ist die ungefähr so vertrauenswürdig wie das TÜV-Siegel für die VZ-Netzwerke oder?
Ah, das würden wir nie so, nein.
Nein, also hier muss man schon sagen, zumindest, das ist rechtlich so vorgesehen und ist auch faktisch so, hier hat die Oberhoheit die BSI, der Bundesamt für Sicherheit, in der Informationstechnik. Das heißt, es ist schon ein technischer Dienstleister der Bundesregierung hier am Start, der eine Zertifizierung macht, wie man sie aus anderen Bereichen, aus IT-Secure, die Bereichen kennt.
Aber die prüfen nur, die prüfen nur, die machen die Zertifizierung nicht selbst. Also die prüfen nur, ob die Zertifizierung ordentlich gelaufen ist.
Und die Zertifizierung wird dann von Dritten?
Genau, das sind Privatunternehmen, die sich selbst auch zertifizieren lassen, dass sie vertrauenswürdige Zertifizierer sind.
Genau, also man vergibt diese Aufträge. Das ist auch tatsächlich gesetzlich so geregelt. Es gibt einen Paragraph 2 und 21 im Bürgerportalgesetz, wo genau, in diesem Amt.
Die E-Mail-Gesetz, wie gesagt, die werden alle immer umbenannt. Das heißt inzwischen auch die E-Mail-Gesetz.
Ich sag immer noch Bürgerportalgesetz. Man hat ja eh Schwierigkeiten, die Sachen auszusetzen.
Im Bezahl-Mail-Gesetz?
Ja, im Bezahl-Mail-Gesetz. Sehr schön. Also das heißt, da ist von der juristischen Perspektive kein Problem. Technisch sehen wir das natürlich anders. Also klar ist das eine Gefahr.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz beim Zertifikat bleiben. Ich hab ja dieses VZ-Ding angesprochen, aus vollem Grund. Da hat der TÜV ja dann später gesagt, naja, wir haben ja diese Software zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt geprüft und als Siegel vergeben. Und da sind ja möglicherweise Änderungen passiert. Wie ist denn das bei den Anbietern? Also beim BSI wird das Zertifikat vergeben oder durch das BSI von Dritten geprüft. Gucken die die ganze Zeit auf diese Systeme? Oder ist es so, die kriegen halt irgendwann Zertifikat und dann liegt die ganze Technik schon auf dem Server des Anbieters und wir müssen quasi darauf vertrauen, dass er so wie das Zertifikat bekommen hat, dass das alles so am Start bleibt.
Also nein, wenn man so die technischen Richtlinien sich anschaut, dann muss der rezertifiziert werden, wenn er Änderungen vornimmt.
Das System ist abgenommen, so wie es angegeben wird. Wenn man dort etwas ändert, dann muss man sich erneut zertifizieren.
Also zumindest dieser Teil jeweils.
So ist es doch festgelegt.
Würdet ihr das jetzt so sagen, also ich muss das ist der Punkt, wo ich euch nochmal fragen muss, wie seht ihr das? Ist das ausreichend oder kann dann trotzdem sozusagen der Anbieteränderung vornehmen?
Jetzt kann man immer sehen, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten man sowas betrachtet. Das eine ist natürlich, dass Zertifizierung in vielen Bereichen ein üblicher Weg ist. Natürlich kann man jetzt wieder sagen, jetzt sind Unternehmen teilweise, wir haben schon über die Telekom gesprochen, die sind bereits mit Datenskandalen und zwar internen Datenskandalen, also wo sie Daten, die sie selbst sammeln, das war ja im Telefonbereich, eben missbraucht haben. Da kann man sich natürlich jetzt wieder fragen, ok, jetzt wenn man annimmt diese Anbieter, dem wird generell vertraut. Ist das eigentlich eine Annahme, die unter diesen Gesichtspunkten valide ist? Aber die juristische Herangehensweise ist natürlich anders. Man betrachtet diesen technischen Komplex als gegeben, wenn die Zertifizierung positiv durchlaufen ist. Also als Hacker sind natürlich immer ein bisschen anders und ich will auch nicht so schnell vergessen, was die Öffentlichkeit offenbar sehr schnell vergisst, nämlich in welcher frechen Weise die ihre Daten da missbraucht haben und da Leute bespitzelt haben und ich sehe nicht unbedingt, dass es nicht bei Anbietern auch weiterhin vorkommen kann. Die Daten sind ja auch finanziell wertvoll. Wirtschaftsspionage ist ja durchaus florierender Graumarkt.
Also aus meiner Sicht noch ein Argument dagegen, dass nämlich die Sicherheit der Signatur und auch der Verschließung sozusagen eigentlich nicht wirklich gegeben ist, weil ich da auf den Anbieter vertrauen muss, was ich bei den normalen Systemen nicht muss.
Das wissen die auch.
Sie müssen das nochmal betonen.
Das wissen die auch. Also das ist nicht so, dass die nicht zugeben, dass jemand, der wirklich Sicherheit haben will, garantierte Sicherheit, der muss sich selbst nochmal extra um Verschließungen kümmern.
Ja, das ist zum Beispiel bei diesem sogenannten Dokumentenspeicher explizit vorgesehen, dass man dort eben nicht unbedingt auf die Verschlüsselung vertrauen muss, die der Anbieter hat, sondern dass man eigene, verschlüsselte Daten in diesem Dokumentenserver ablegen kann.
Okay, also nochmal. Im De-Mail-Gesetz gibt es eine optional Komponente, die heißt Dokumentensafe. De-Safe. Und in diesem De-Safe, der ist dazu da, um meine Dokumente sicher aufzubewahren, aber ich muss mich selber um Verschlüsselung kümmern. Hab ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Man kann dort auch verschlüsselte Dokumente ablegen, die man selbst verschlüsselt hat. Da geht es denen darum, dass natürlich für diese Nachschlüsse, die wir schon angesprochen haben, wenn man also etwa seinen eigenen Schlüssel nicht mehr...
Das meinte ich gerade. Sie stellen einen sicheren Dokumenten sich zur Verfügung, sagen aber, wenn ihr wirklich eure Dokumente sicher abschmeichern wollt, dann müsst ihr sie selber verschlüsseln.
Ja, so sagen sie es natürlich nicht, aber in gewisser Weise.
Aber das ist die Konsequenz.
In gewisser Weise schon.
Diese Nachschlüsselproblematik ist natürlich für viele Leute ein großes Problem und überhaupt die Tatsache, dass eben die Verschlüsselung nicht von Ende zu Ende ist. Denn jemand mit Verstand wird immer versuchen wollen, die Verschlüsselung im eigenen Hoheitsbereich in der Kontrolle zu haben und von Ende zu Ende zu verschlüsseln, und zwar ohne Unterbrechung, ohne ein Sicherheitsrisiko in der Mitte, und das heißt De-Mail. Das ist tatsächlich ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Ich würde das persönlich inakzeptabel finden.
Also es ist der eine Punkt sozusagen, dass die Anbieter selber, dass man dem vertrauen muss, aber wir gehen jetzt mal von dem Fall, den ihr natürlich nie befürworten würdet, aber wir gehen jetzt mal von aus, der Anbieter sei vertrauenswürdig. Jetzt ist es ja bei dieser sogenannten Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, was er genannt hat, also GPG und PGP, so dass die Software, die dem zugrunde liegt, ist open source. Das heißt, jeder kann sich den Quellcode angucken. Das heißt auch, die Verschlüsselung basiert nicht darauf, dass ich sozusagen geheim halte, wie sie funktioniert, also so im Sinne von, haha, ihr wisst nicht, wie es geht, deswegen könnt ihr es auch nicht entlüsseln, sondern das funktioniert mathematisch. Wie ist es bei diesem System? Ist in diesem Gesetzeskonzept vorgesehen, dass die Software, die die Anbieter verwenden, auch so in einem Prüfprozess durch die Community ausgesetzt ist? Oder dürfen die sozusagen da im geheimen Kämmerlein werken, was sie da machen?
Also nein, der Community wird da überhaupt nichts übergeholfen, was Prüfprozesse oder so angeht.
Nein, das ist auch nicht open source.
Es muss auch nicht open source sein. Andererseits, sie fordern, dass die Sicherheit nach dem Stand der Technik garantiert wird. Und die Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die eingesetzt werden, dem Stand der Technik entsprechen.
Das ist aber natürlich nur juristische Definition. Der Stand der Technik ist nur von Juristen definiert und nicht unbedingt, wie wir Stand der Technik jetzt als Techies verstehen würden.
Also man könnte sagen, hingehen und sagen, so Stand der Technik ist open source Verschlüsselung?
Also Stand der Technik ist eigentlich open source Verschlüsselung. Stand der Technik ist auch, dass die Verfahren alle offen liegen. Damit am Ende tatsächlich das Einzige, was geheim bleiben soll, ist der Schlüssel.
Das heißt aber, das müsste man im Zweifel einklagen?
Um das mal nicht zu formulieren, ich glaube, da ist niemand in Klage befugt. Also ich glaube, das kannst du einfach nicht vor Gericht durchsetzen.
Also das heißt sozusagen, wir müssen nicht nur vertrauen, dass der Anbieter nichts Böses will, wir müssen auch darauf vertrauen, dass der Anbieter technisch kompetent ist, weil wir können die Verschlüsselungsprogrammierung nicht selber nachprüfen. Sind die Anbieter, die derzeit Telekom, Post, GMX, United Internet, sind die denn als vertrauenswürdig einzustufen?
Also ich würde nicht mal sagen, dass das BSI vertrauenswürdig ist. Das Problem ist, die haben selbst...
Jetzt kommt Jörg mit den dicken Dingen.
Na ja, die haben selbst ein Verschlüsselungsangebot, das heißt Chiasmus oder Chiasmus. Und das basiert darauf, dass das ganze Verfahren geheim ist. Also das Verfahren ist nicht offengelegt.
Man nennt es Security by Obscurity.
Genau.
Das heißt, man vertraut darauf, dass durch Nichtkenntnis eine höhere Sicherheit gewährleistet ist. Das ist natürlich aus technischer Sicht fragwürdig und ist auch sehr oft gescheitert.
Und das ist seit 120 Jahren out das Verfahren.
Okay, also auf meiner Liste steht jetzt ein Punkt 4. Technische Kompetenz der Anbieter ist fragwürdig. Und wir kommen jetzt nochmal zurück. Mit den Anrufern haben wir so kleine Zeitsprünge. Es geht jetzt nochmal um einen Spam. Und da hat Edwin angerufen. Hallo. Möchtest du bei den E-Mails spammen? Oder warum rufst du an?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir hatten vorhin ganz kurz die Argumentation, dass ein User sich gesorgt hat, dass Spam über generische Verfahren möglich wäre. Nochmal sozusagen ein Themenwechsel. Ich denke nicht, dass das möglich sein wird. Und zwar aus dem folgenden Grund, da spammen wir ja eigentlich den Vorteil der normalen E-Mail-Ausnutzung, die kostenlos sind.
Du meinst, die Kostenpflichtigkeit wird die sicher abstoßen?
Ja, das ist jetzt der eine Punkt. Dann könnte man sagen, okay, eventuell hacken sie irgendeinen Account und verschicken es über den einen. Es ist aber so, dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch nicht einen kostenlosen E-Mail-Anbieter habe, sondern einen kommerziellen. Und der verbietet mir sozusagen, mehr als 200 E-Mails in der Stunde zu verschicken. Also da denke ich, gäbe es schon einige sinnvolle Beschränkungen auf Provider oder Serviceanbieterseite, um sowas zu verändern.
Also das heißt, du würdest sagen, die Werbung damit, dass Spam damit sicher bekämpft wird, könnte schon ein paar valide Punkte haben?
Denke ich auf jeden Fall. Und prinzipiell sehe ich schon ein paar Punkte, die sinnvoll sind bei der De-Mail.
Ja, nämlich?
Zum Beispiel wäre auch der Umweltschutz ein Thema, wo man sagen könnte, langfristig gesehen, klar, jetzt am Anfang, wo es so eine Umstiegsphase ist, wo praktisch viel noch per Brief gemacht wird oder Post halt klassisch. Und manche Leute das sozusagen noch nicht haben, dann müsste das da ausgedruckt werden. Dann ist es auch die Frage, ob das umweltschützend ist. Aber prinzipiell haben wir ja heute fast jeder Computer. Da ist es schon sinnvoll, dass man irgendwann mal auf die digitale Welt umspringt. Ob das System so wie es gemacht wird, sinnvoller ist, das ist die Frage.
Wir hatten ja diese ökologische Komponente schon zweimal so ein bisschen gestreift. Leider ist es natürlich so, dass sich in diesem sechsmonatigen Test in einer T-City in Friedrichshafen hat sich jetzt natürlich nicht bewahrheitet. Das liegt natürlich daran, dass genau wie du sagst, dieser Ernstprozess noch nicht so durchgestylt war, dass man also zwischendurch doch wieder drucken musste und dass sie sogar so ein paar Blüten da eingebaut haben, wie wenn man sich jetzt auf den Portal eingeloggt hat als Testnutzer bei De-Mail und versucht hat, seine De-Mail zu bekommen. Man hat dreimal ein paar Passworte eingegeben und hat man per Post ein neues zugeschickt bekommen. Also da waren einfach noch viele Sachen, die sich erst wohl einrütteln müssen, sofern die Leute eben mitmachen. Dann kann natürlich schon durchaus sein, dass das ein Rohrkrepierer wird. Das wollen wir mal sehen, ob sich die Investitionen da wirklich lohnen. Aber ich sehe deinen Punkt. Klar, alle wünschen sich seit, weiß ich nicht, wie lange, 15, 20 Jahre, Papierlose Büro. Leider ist ja das Gegenteil eingetreten. Also wir müssen mal über das Volumen reden. Wir reden über etwa 20 Milliarden Briefe innerhalb von Deutschland. Das ist also, was die Post so angibt. Und davon sind derzeit, zumindest nach den groben Schätzungen der Post, etwa die Hälfte Briefe mit juristischem Belang. Da natürlich diese ganze private Korrespondenz einen stark abgenommen. Wer schreibt schon noch einen Brief, wo er eine E-Mail schicken kann? Und deshalb ist natürlich der Anteil an Briefen, die irgendwie geschäftlich, behördlich, aber jedenfalls eine Rechtsfolge haben, schon mit 50 Prozent sehr hoch. Irgendwie habe ich dieses Ökodokument, Argumente finde ich schon valide. Ich würde mir auch wünschen, dass da viel automatisiert werden könnte. Man muss natürlich auch mal an Leute denken, wie sie in den Friedrichshafen an Anwendungstests durchgespielt wurden. Wir nehmen mal Aufenthaltsgenehmigungen, die zum Beispiel elektronisch erteilt werden. Man muss dann halt nicht mehr zum Arbeitsamt und zur Ausländerbehörde, sondern kann klicken. Das ist natürlich schon praktisch. Oder bei einer Geburt, jeder, der ein Kind gekriegt hat, weiß, dass es unglaublich viele Behördengänge gibt. Und zwar innerhalb von kurzer Zeit. Da freut man sich schon, wenn man diese Urkunde zur Geburt eben kriegen kann digital. Ich sehe die Argumente, aber guckt man sich das dann genauer an?
Einen kleinen Punkt hätte ich auch noch, wenn ich durfte. Wie sieht es denn aus mit normalen E-Mails im bisherigen Geschäftsbereich? Also wir haben auch ein fast papierloses Büro, haben aber jetzt nicht, so wie ein User am Anfang der Sendung erklärt hat, dass dann hinterher eine Mail zurückgeschickt wird, okay, wir haben die E-Mail empfangen, aber machen eigentlich schon eigentlich sehr viel per normaler E-Mail. Ist das dann eigentlich ein rechtsgültiges Geschäft oder kann man das dann hinterher sagen, wir haben eigentlich gar keinen Vertrag?
Nein, die meisten Rechtsgeschäfte kann man formfrei schließen, die kann man per Handschlag schließen, die kann man mündlich schließen, oder kann man eben auch per E-Mail schließen.
Also dann geht es eigentlich nur darum, dass es wirklich die behördlichen Dinge sind, oder?
Ja, du kannst natürlich auch mal denken, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel in ein anderes Unternehmen zukaufst, also wenn es ein Rechtsgeschäft ist, das unglaublich viele andere Vertragsfolgen hat und so weiter, dann ist es natürlich etwas anderes, als wenn du mit einem Kunden jetzt einen Vertrag abschließt.
Wobei das auch Grenzen hat, also nicht alles, auch die De-Mail übernimmt nicht alles in rechtlicher Hinsicht. Also es entspricht zum Beispiel nicht der Schriftform. Also wenn irgendein Gesetz Schriftformen vorschreibt, dann reicht die De-Mail auch nicht aus.
Was?
Das sagt ihr jetzt?
Das ist ja aber auch mal interessant.
Nach anderthalb Stunden erfahren wir, dass die De-Mail, die den Brief ersetzen soll, nicht die Schriftform ersetzt.
Männer immer mit der Ruhe. Nein, der Punkt ist doch, es ist schon klar, dass sich viele andere Rechtsnormen, die wir in verschiedenen Gesetzen haben, die irgendwelche Papierformen vorschreiben, die müssen sich natürlich nach und nach anpassen. Das ist aber auch der Plan.
Es gibt schon...
Also man kann schon elektronische Formen wählen. Also das heißt, mit Hilfe von irgendwie mit einer qualifizierten elektronischen Signatur nach einem Signaturgesetz kann man sozusagen wie bei der Schriftform genau die gleichen Verträge unterschreiben oder was auch immer.
Okay, das würde bei mir jetzt sofort die Frage nach sich ziehen. Es gibt also ein Gesetz über eine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Genau. Warum ist das bei der De-Mail keine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur?
Das liegt daran, dass es nicht mal eine fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur ist.
Was aber immer das bedeutet?
Also es gibt so ein Drei-Stufen-System. Eine einfache elektronische Signatur, eine fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur und eine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Und die qualifizierte elektronische Signatur kann die eigenhändige Namensunterschrift ersetzen.
Warum ist das bei De-Mail nicht so?
Das liegt daran, dass schon die fortgeschrittene elektronische Signatur voraussetzt, dass du den Computer, auf dem die Signatur erstellt wird, unter deiner Kontrolle hast. Und wie wir das vorhin gesagt haben, bei De-Mail wird die Signatur auf dem Server vollzogen.
Ich gebe auf. Das ist die Stelle, an der ich jetzt aufgebe. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, um weiter drüber zu reden. Nee, ich gebe nicht auf im Sinne von, ich verstehe nichts mehr, sondern ich gebe auf im Sinne von, ich gebe die Hoffnung auf, dass dieses System irgendwann noch mal zu irgendeiner Spruchreife kommt, die mir vertrauenswürdig erscheint. Nee, damit warten wir jetzt bis nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaosradio noch eine halbe Stunde mit mir, Markus Richter und mit Konstanze Kurz vom Chaos Computer Club und mit Jörg Pohle von der Humboldt-Uni Berlin. Es geht um die De-Mail. De-Mail, die also mir sozusagen, ich habe diesmal so begegnet, dass man gesagt hat, okay, früher gab es Briefe von den Behörden, jetzt soll es De-Mail geben. Also Behörden schreiben euch und das ist dann alles sozusagen, das hat auch so Behördentouch, soll also irgendwie sicher sein. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine halbe Stunde rausgefunden, das ersetzt nicht die Schriftform, dazu müsste es dann nochmal extra Zeug geben. Außerdem gibt es schon vier Punkte, die auf meiner Liste stehen, die mich dazu bringen wollen, dass ich eigentlich die E-Mail wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden werde. Das eine ist sozusagen, wenn euch eine De-Mail geschickt wird und euer Anbieter sagt, ich hab die bekommen, dann gilt die als gelesen. Das heißt, dann fangen die juristischen Schriften, Fristen anzulaufen. Dann liegen diese Mails ja bei den Anbietern. Und da können jede Menge Behörden und andere Institutionen ziemlich einfach darauf zugreifen. Es werden Zertifikate vergeben, die die technische Zuverlässigkeit der Anbieter sozusagen zertifizieren. Also das ist alles OK-Stempel, aber die Art und Weise, wie die vergeben werden, ist ein bisschen fragwürdig. Und dasselbe gilt auch für die technische Kompetenz der Anbieter. Wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Müssen wir noch weiter reden?
Ja, wir haben noch total tolle Argumente, die wir auch noch bringen müssen. Also, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die, wenn man sich das angesehen hat, bei der Deutschen Post, die ja den E-Postbrief hat, die sie jetzt bewirbt und der Martell werden soll, der De-Mail oder das ganze De-Mail-Projekt ist, dann fällt einem bei der Registrierung gleich was auf. Die haben doch tatsächlich, die haben sich nicht entblödet, gleichzeitig zu der Registrierung, zu ihrem E-Postbrief ein Gewinnspiel anzubieten. Und da fiel mir jetzt ein bisschen wie schuppenvoll in den Augen, was die meisten Leute glaube ich nicht wissen. Und was in Deutschland wenig bekannt ist, ist, dass die Deutsche Post einer der größten Adresshändler in Deutschland sind, die also in kleinen und in großen Tranchen für kommerzielle und private Anbieter Adressen vertickt. Und die nicht nur Adressenlisten vertickt, sondern die auch Korrekturen für Adresslisten, die man schon hat, macht. Also zum Beispiel wenn da Vornamen oder Taipos drin sind, so was korrigiert die. Es ist ein sehr großer Adresshändler. Und es ist glaube ich vielen nicht bewusst, die sich da registrieren. Aber dieses Gewinnspiel fand ich so sehr lustig, weil man kann den Haken setzen oder nicht innerhalb der Bedingungen, die sich die Post da selber gegeben hat und die man natürlich unterzeichnen muss.
Fürs Gewinnspiel oder für die De-Mail?
Für die De-Mail wird die Weitergabe dieser Adressen nämlich nicht ausgeschlossen. Das heißt, ob man bei dem Gewinnspiel mitmacht oder nicht. Man kann trotzdem auf tolle neue Preise ausschreiben, warten. Und entsprechend ist uns als Chaos Computer Club in den letzten Tagen von Betriebsräten der Deutschen Post zugegangen, also E-Mail zugegangen, die sich so desinformiert fühlen von ihrem eigenen Arbeitgeber, dass sie gerne mal das technische Konzept eigentlich erklärt bekommen haben wollen vom Chaos Computer Club.
Mitarbeiter der Firma, die den E-Postbrief... Betriebsräte sind ja auch Mitarbeiter, oder nicht?
Ja schon, aber die haben ja meist noch einen anderen Blick auf uns.
Naja, aber trotzdem. Es sind sozusagen Mitarbeiter der Firma, die das Produkt anbieten.
Genau, die haben nämlich folgendes gemacht in ihrer Betriebsratssitzung. Die haben sich die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen mal gemeinschaftlich durchgelesen. Dabei haben sie entdeckt, da steht was ganz anderes als in der hochpolierten Werbung. Und das ist ihnen natürlich dabei aufgefallen, denn wir können nur jedem empfehlen, sich diese AGB mal durchzulesen. Es lohnt sich hier, denn es sind doch einige Zumutungen.
Katze, hast du mal so Tipps jetzt, damit wir nicht alle jetzt irgendwie...
Es geht vor allen Dingen um Adresshandel. Und da muss man sich schon fragen, was hat sich da die Post dabei gedacht? Wir wissen, dass das bei der Post ein Geschäftsmodell seit Jahren ist, um Adressen zu vererticken. Und die meisten Leute sind gegenüber der Post sehr ehrlich. Sie sagen ihnen sogar sehr schnell, wann sie umziehen, weil sie natürlich ihre Post bekommen wollen. Die haben immer den aktuellsten Datenbestand.
Dürfen die denn das?
Natürlich dürfen die das. Wenn man registriert, dann wird man dem zustimmen.
Wir haben jetzt noch Mandy. Du wolltest uns was zur Sicherheit in Behörden erzählen.
Wir wissen ja, Elena ist sehr fortgeschritten. Ich hab einfach nur mein Kind in der Kita angemettet. Auf einmal wussten die, was ich im ganzen Haus schon mal beantragt habe. Wie weit ist es denn kompatibel? Weil ich sag mal, wenn es so ein Portal ist, wo man viele Behördensachen machen kann, sind die gleichzusetzen mit Elena? Er setzt das vielleicht irgendwo an Elena? Weil es ist ja dann umfangs praktisch mit einem System theoretisch zu arbeiten. Und wie weit kriege ich denn eigentlich vielleicht so eine Bemerkung, dass sich irgendjemand meine Akte doch mal aufgerufen hat? Oder mit Kollegen mit anderen Abteilungen zusammenarbeiten? Weil ich habe die Sache auch nur durch Zufall eigentlich so rausbekommen. Wo ich sagte, okay, man muss halt auch wahnsinnig aufpassen.
Also natürlich, wir haben mit der Ernst zum Anfang erwähnt, dieses Projekt, die E-Mail und die Gesetzgebung und die Rechtsverordnungen und dann alle dazugehört, ist natürlich schon Teil der High-Tech-Strategie der Bundesregierung, wozu natürlich viele andere Projekte gehören, die eben möglichst dafür sorgen sollen, dass diese Gesellschaft mal irgendwann im digitalen Zeitalter ankommt. Aber zumindest aus meiner Kenntnis gibt es bisher überhaupt keinen Zusammenhang zu diesem Entgeltnachweis. Elena und wir konnten da auch bisher keine Hinweise finden. Natürlich gibt es Szenarien, die immer wieder in den Konzepten auftauchten, zum Beispiel, dass man die Bürger, die ja nicht so richtig Lust hatten, in den vergangenen Jahren bei solchen Systemen mitzumachen, die Freiwilligkeit mal vielleicht ein bisschen nach vorne bringt, indem man etwa sagt, naja, die Finanzbehörden schicken ihre Steuerbescheide über De-Mail raus. Oder so was in der Zukunft natürlich. Damit hätte man natürlich eine sehr starke Inzentivierung. Das heißt, Leute würden, weil Steuerbescheide eben ganz viele Leute betreffen, da mitmachen oder eben vielleicht Bescheide vom Arbeitsamt, vom Ausländeramt. Also solche Fragen. Aber bisher sehen wir keine konkreten Hinweise, dass es Verbindungen zu Elendr gibt.
Also zu Elendr direkt nicht. Aber Elster hat genau das gleiche. Die gleiche Funktionsweise. Eigentlich dient es der Kommunikation zwischen dem Bürger oder dem Unternehmen und der Steuerbehörde.
Also Elster ist die elektronische, die Abgabe.
Eigentlich praktisch so wie Intranet oder so.
Elektronische Steuererklärung.
Genau, das ist dieses Elster-System, wo man ja unter manchen Umständen, also manche sind ja bereits gezwungen, das elektronisch einzureichen.
Selbstständige zum Beispiel.
Ja, das war ja auch komisch. Dann haben wir Anfangs von ganz anderen Abteilungen bekommen, die uns damit jetzt nicht so richtig zu tun haben. Und dann denkt man auch, okay, die nächsten wissen eigentlich Bescheid, denen haben die eigentlich ja Einfluss drauf. Und wenn ich eigentlich nur eine Sache beantragen will, wissen vielleicht fünf Abteilungen. Und wenn man auch vielleicht nur ganz einfache Anträge stellt, einfach um mal Dinge nachzufragen, und dann auf einmal an ganz anderen Abteilungen landen und man sagt, man will eigentlich ja nur nachfragen, was ich beim Jugendamt mit irgendwelchen Umgangsformen, man hat eigentlich nur eine Anfrage, keine konkrete Ausführung.
Du hast so eher diese Angst, dass es stärker integriert wird und verschiedene Behörden auf dieselben Datenbestände zugreifen. Ist das etwas, was ich da rausgesungen habe?
Man muss das einfach nur ein Stück weiter denken. Und jetzt noch ein anderer Punkt ist, was nennt man ja doch gerade bei älteren Leuten oder bei Behinderten oder was ich, die bestimmte Sachen vielleicht auch nicht so alleine machen können. Und ja, beim Papierkram, okay, dann braucht man vielleicht auch noch jemand. Aber so im Internet, das heißt, man muss auch erstmal...
Ich kann dir jetzt in der Tat nicht mehr ganz folgen. Im Prinzip sagst du, das System ist dir auch nichts, weil sozusagen das...
Nee, das ist jetzt ein zweiter Punkt. Wenn jetzt irgendwann wirklich nur der Computer, das heißt, wir müssen ja den Leuten auch wirklich auch einen Anschluss haben.
Das ist ja momentan noch freiwillig, also so weit sind wir noch nicht. Das wäre in der Tat auch mal ein zweiter Punkt, den man aber glaube ich erst in so keine Ahnung, zwei bis fünf Jahren diskutieren könnte, ob und wie viel man schon gezwungen ist und ob es ohne Computer überhaupt noch geht. Aber das ist glaube ich heute nicht ganz so das Thema, sondern das ist De-Mail. Das ist ja im Moment auch eine freiwillige Sache, die aber schon dazu dienen soll, dass man quasi von Behörden Schreiben in Empfang nehmen kann, wenn man will. Und zum Empfangen dieser Schreiben hat Murdoch noch eine Frage.
Und zwar wollte ich eigentlich sagen, dass ich das eigentlich auch ein bisschen unverständlich finde, dass wenn eine E-Mail ankommt und ich ruf sie nicht ab, dass sie zugestellt gilt. Und zwar wollte ich eigentlich nur dazu bemerken, am 7. Juli 2009 hat das Landgericht Hamburg in einen Fall, wo jemand eine Abmahnung per E-Mail geschickt hat, die hat er nicht gekriegt, weil die Firewall, die geblockt hat, beschlossen, dass die E-Mail trotzdem als angekommen und somit als verfüggerecht und so weiter.
Ja, aber das war seine eigene Firewall. Also das muss man halt auch sagen. Solche Entscheidungen sind dann immer sehr auf den Einzelfall fixiert. Und es war wohl seine eigene Firewall, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, Landgericht Hamburg, müssen wir da mehr sagen.
Die Internet-Spezialisten.
Aber da sieht man halt sowas, die gehen ähnliche Wege. Und das ist natürlich ein Ding, ehrlich gesagt, was ich auch nicht schön finde. Ich glaube, ich beim postalischen Weg, ähnliche Gesetze, wenn das Ding in Briefkasten landet, ist eigentlich erst mal zugestellt, angewiesen. Somit hat er das erhalten und muss eigentlich darauf reagieren. Auch wenn das noch nicht geöffnet hat.
Ja, aber eben nicht bei der Poststelle. Das heißt, wenn du den Schriebs bekommst in deinen Briefkasten, dass zum Beispiel ein Einschreiben da ist, dann gilt es erst dann als Empfangen, wenn du dahin gehst und es abholst.
Das Einschreiben, nicht nur den Zettel.
Genau.
Und das ist nämlich genau der Unterschied, den wir versucht haben, von dieser Briefwelt in die digitale Welt zu erklären. Also sie haben es vorverlegt. Und zwar außerhalb deines Machtbereiches, in der Briefkasse, ist dein Machtbereich aber nicht etwa, was da bei dem Server, bei dem Anbieter liegt. Das ist, was wir gerade sagen wollten. Also ich lese eine Wisse Grundeskepsis auch bei dir heraus, richtig?
Definitiv. Also ich hab auch die ganzen News bei den ganzen Alt-V-News gelesen, über die E-Post und hatte auch kurz nachdem auch schon Werbung davon im Briefkasten. Und hatte aber schon einiges gelesen und werde mich definitiv dann natürlich anmelden. Ein Freund von mir hat das gleich getan am ersten Tag.
Und hat er eine Nummer gekriegt oder hat er noch seinen eigenen Vornamen?
Ich hab ihn gar nicht gefragt. Aber er ist so Early Adapter, also davon ab, er wollte einfach so gleiten, als er es ist daran. Und das war so der Punkt.
Jetzt haben wir immerhin schon sagen, von zwei Leuten gehört, die zumindest da mitgemacht haben. Jetzt nehmen wir noch Benni dazu. Der hat eine Frage zum Löschen von Dokumenten. Benni, was genau meinst du?
Ja, guten Abend. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt E-Mails oder Dokumente löschen möchte, ist das überhaupt möglich? Oder werden die dann auch vom Anbieter vernichtet? Oder sind die dann immer noch irgendwo auf dem Surfer und zugreifbar für Strafverfolgungsbehörden oder Ähnliches?
Also die sollen dann schon gelöscht werden. Die Deutsche Post, die ja diesen E-Postbrief anbietet, die schreibt allerdings in ihrer AGB, dass das durchaus eine ganze Weile dauern kann und dass sie keine Gewähr dafür übernimmt, dass das sofort gelöscht wird. Oder auch nur in näherer Zukunft.
Ja, das ist auch ein Kritikpunkt, der jetzt häufiger einfach genannt wird. Da man natürlich in der eigenen Sphäre sagen kann, also löschig, und zwar gelöscht wirklich sicher, kann man natürlich nicht unbedingt bei dem Anbieter, muss man sich aber jeweils an die AGB durchlesen. Wir haben ja quasi für diesen speziellen Fall nur diese einen AGB, die schon vorliegen.
Das ist dann aber auch nicht im Zertifizierungsprozess vorgesehen, dass da irgendwie übers Löschen mitzertifiziert wird.
Die werden gerade in die Köpfe gewiegt, man weiß nicht so genau, oder?
Also das Löschen wird zumindest in den technischen Richtlinien angesprochen. Auch, dass es halt geschehen muss.
Und dass es auch einen technischen Vorgang geben muss, der auch beschrieben sein muss. Das ist auf jeden Fall in den Richtlinien mit drin.
Also es wird anders als mit sozialen Netzwerken, wo man den Account gar nicht löschen kann.
Na, da wird als gelöscht markiert.
Okay, also wir wissen es doch nicht genau, aber es soll auf jeden Fall irgendwie stattfinden. Ich hoffe, das hat jetzt weitergeholfen.
Ich wollte eigentlich Benni mir was fragen.
Wir haben nicht mehr so richtig viel Zeit. Und dann hat Paul angerufen, was ich spannend finde, weil er ja am Anfang der Sendung auch angerufen hat.
Hast du dir mal überlegt, wer das bezahlt?
Die Löscherei, oder wie?
Nein, die ganze Projekt, die De-Mail, wer bezahlt das eigentlich?
Der Steuerzahler.
Ja, und der Gebührenzahler, genau. Und wer hat was davon?
Die Behörden.
Also, na, und die Unternehmen, denn die sollen da sparen. Ich finde diese, wem nützt das eigentlich, Frage immer ganz spannend.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also bei der Post sozusagen, die nimmt dasselbe Geld pro Mail an wie für einen Brief, hat aber viel weniger Aufriss damit.
Nicht wahr? Aber wir bezahlen zwar Gebühren und Steuern. Naja, ich meine ja nur. Wollen wir jetzt mal Paul versuchen?
Genau, jetzt fragen wir noch Paul. Paul hat ja am Anfang der Sendung angerufen. Hallo Paul.
Ja, hallo nochmal.
Und am Anfang war deine Meinung zu die E-Mail was gewesen?
Ja, ich hab gesagt, dass ich es privat nicht nutzen werde, weil ich so meine E-Mails auch sonst, also jetzt nicht Sorgen habe, dass sie mitgelesen werden, etc. dass ich bei Behörden, dass ich da das nicht brauche, dass da ja die Moment auch noch also schön per Brief kommen. Und ich glaube, das war so meine Meinung, oder? Ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt keinen Punkt vergessen.
Das kann man alles nochmal im Podcast nachhören, wenn man sich nicht genau weiß, was Paul gesagt hat. Aber wie ist sie denn jetzt gerade?
Ja, und sie hat sich auch nicht wirklich geändert.
Was?
Ich habe für mich jetzt entschlossen, dass wenn es jetzt so heißt, dass alle für Behördengänge sowas brauchen, wenn sie Internet haben, dann muss ich es ja so oder so haben. Aber wenn es nur eine Option ist, dass man so seine Behördenbriefe empfängt, dann werde ich es lassen. Also entweder, wenn man die dann optional angeben kann, die De-Mail-Adresse oder die Mail-Adresse, dass ich die dann einfach nicht angebe. Oder wenn man eine hat, dass man dann automatisch in dem System drin ist, dass ich die dann wieder lösche.
Aber wir haben uns doch so müde gegeben, Werbung zu machen. Hat bei dir wohl nicht so gefruchtet?
Nee.
Es gibt ein tolles Gewinnspiel. Zumindest bei der Post.
Aber dann habe ich auch, glaube ich, hoffe ich jedenfalls, nicht diese AGB-Klausel, dass ich...
Würde ich erst mal nachlesen.
Das solltest du auf jeden Fall.
Also jedenfalls, als ich mich angemeldet habe, musste ich nichts ankreuzen, dass ich den AGB...
Nee, da hast du mich dran. Es gibt dieses Gewinnspiel, aber es ist sowieso in...
Na, wenn du schon vorher Kunde warst, dann hast du natürlich ihren AGB zuvor bereits zugestimmt.
Da müssen sie mich aber informieren, dass ihre AGBs geändert haben.
Ja, vielleicht haben sie es aber nicht geändert. Kann ja sein, dass die gleich geblieben sind.
Gut, dann wünschen wir viel Spaß mit ohne De-Mail, weil so richtig durchgesetzt hat sich das System eigentlich nicht. Also auch auf meiner Liste stehen immer noch die vier Punkte, die dagegen sprechen, als da wären, dass die De-Mail das so handhaben soll, dass es als Empfang gilt. Also ich habe die Mail bekommen, wenn sie beim Anbieter in meinem Postkasten liegt, die juristischen Fristen fangen an zu laufen. Ziemlich viele Leute können darauf zugreifen, zwar unter juristischen Bedingungen, aber die sind jetzt nicht so schwer einzuhalten. Die Zertifikatsvergabe zur technischen Sicherheit ist so ein bisschen so, dass ich denke, okay, das ist nicht ganz sicher. Und auch die technische Kompetenz der Anbieter von De-Mail sind eher als fragwürdig hier.
Da möchte man vor allem das Wort T-Systems hier mal einwerfen.
Es macht das nicht besser.
Du hast was vergessen, das fünfte Argument.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade fragen, abschließende Worte von Konstanze Kurz von Chaos Computer Club und Jörg Pohle von der Universität zu Berlin, aber bitte.
Nein, ich glaube, das fünfte Argument sollte man schon dazu nehmen. Also zu fragen, welchem Anbieter gibt man da seine Daten? Bei der Post als großem Adresshändler oder bei der Telekom als bekanntem Datenskandalist ist das glaube ich schon eine Frage, die sich unter 5 einsortiert. Aber wir hatten eigentlich, wir hatten als wir über die Sendung gesprochen haben auch noch einen interessanten Punkt zu dieser Namensvergabe. Das heißt jetzt De-Mail. Und dann haben wir uns gefragt, wie spricht man das eigentlich? Spricht man eine De-Mail? De-Mail? Wie spricht man das eigentlich? Und uns fiel auf, dass diese Vorsilbe ja auch in anderen deutschen Worten üblich ist. Sowas wie de-anonymisieren, de-maskieren. Und wir fanden dieses Spiel mit dem Wort eigentlich ganz interessant. So ein bisschen wie, also eben wie eine De-Mail im Gegensatz zu Gratis-Mail. Jetzt bezahlen wir die De-Mails. Und da wir jetzt aktuell so viel über Depublizieren reden, weil ja die öffentlich-rechtlichen leider so viel Inhalte aus dem Netz rausnehmen müssen, fanden wir diese diese Anwandlung irgendwie schön.
Was ich jetzt als letzte Frage noch hätte ist, jemand meinte, man könnte ja, siehst du, eine De-Mail-Adresse zulegen und dann Mails verschicken und zwar Fishing-Mails.
Ah ja, weil du dich ausweisen willst dafür, dass du Fischer bist?
Nee, eher so im Sinne von, guck mal, hier ist eine signierte De-Mail, geh mal auf das Portal und log dich ein, wir brauchen dringend deine neuen Zugangsdaten.
Ich fände das eine gute Methode, die Quote derjenigen, die dort reinfallen, könnte höher sein als im normalen Gratis-Mail-Geschäft.
Das ist tatsächlich auch der Grund, warum die Aussage, dass Spam wird darüber nicht funktionieren, nicht so stimmt. Die wissen das schon, das ist der Grund, warum sie das auf 100 versendete De-Mails pro Tag beschränken, weil sie sich natürlich darüber im Klaren sind, dass sowas wie Phishing, so was wie Malware auf dem Rechner...
Ja, man muss natürlich auch mal daran... Also, dass das generisch zu die Adresse zu berechnen ist, das ist ein Fakt. Nur die Frage, wie benutzt wird das einander. Man muss aber, glaube ich, ein paar Beispiele, die wir bisher noch nicht hatten, dazu nehmen. Also, das ist nicht nur immer Vornahme, Nachname, sondern das kann durchaus auch das, was im Ausweis steht sein. Also etwa ein Künstlernname oder ein Ordensname, auch das ist möglich. Also, die haben alle Möglichkeiten, die auf deutschen Ausweisen stehen können. Dazu hier noch die juristische Person. Das kann man eben schön generieren.
Na ja, da steht uns also einiges bevor. Tja, das war es also zur De-Mail. Ich fürchte, die hat heute nicht Fans dazu gewonnen. Würde mich zumindest ein bisschen wundern. Diese Sendung möchte ich dann sozusagen hiermit abschließen. Und den beiden Experten vor Ort recht herzlichen Dank sagen, dass ihr da wart. Und euch für eure Anrufe. Aber es ist ja auch traditionell so, dass dieser letzte Mittwoch im Monat dazu benutzt wird, dass der Chaos Computer Club Werbung für Dinge macht, die so passieren bei dem. Also manchmal passiert sonntags im Club was. Quatsch, sonntags, Donnerstags, da kann man hinkommen. Steht da was an?
Nee, wir planen derzeit keinen Datengarten. Aber wir haben da immer diese große Veranstaltung zum Jahresende.
Ich hab mich schon gefragt, ob die stattfindet, weil hätte man nicht um diese Zeit schon was hören sollen.
Ja, also wir bereiten derzeit den Call for Papers vor. Das heißt, wir werden in sehr kurzer Zeit die ersten Einreichungen für den Chaos Communication Congress zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr entgegennehmen. Und ich darf auch noch hinweisen auf die Veranstaltung Datenspuren in Dresden, die wieder stattfindet. Also da im Chaos Computer Club sind immer viele Aktivitäten zu beobachten. Und wer noch nicht unsere elf Forderungen für eine gesunde, gute, zukunftsträchtige Netzpolitik gelesen hat, der sollte mal auf ccc.de klicken, denn ich glaube, es lohnt sich da mal.
Also ihr macht doch wirklich jeden Scheiß mit, oder? Netzthesen schreiben?
Das sind nicht Thesen, das sind Forderungen.
Entschuldigung. Aber noch mal genauer zu Datenspuren. Wann?
Oh, ich hatte das Datum jetzt gar nicht. Jörg hat den Recherch. Jörg muss nachgucken, ist schuld.
Okay, dann erzähl doch währenddessen, was da passiert.
Die Datenspuren sind insofern immer ein sehr interessantes Symposium, weil das so eine kleine, schöne Location in Dresden ist, wo man noch ein bisschen mehr als beim Kongress diese Vorlesungshafte verliert. Man kann also viel Hands-on, viel Workshops, aber man kann vor allen Dingen gut debattieren, weil das sind immer keine Tausende, sondern hunderte Leute, ein bisschen kleiner. Das ist übrigens komplett kostenlos. Und da läuft gerade auch der Call for Papers, also wer sich da gerne wieder eine Idee hat, das ist vom 16. bis 17. Oktober, also ein schönes Wochenende im wunderbaren Dresden, was übrigens immer eine Reise wert ist.
Noch eine Weile hin. Okay, aber wisst ihr Bescheid, diese Sendung gibt es als Podcast, demnächst gleich sofort auf fritz.de, später dann auch noch auf chaosradio.de. Könnt ihr euch dort ziehen. Wir übergeben jetzt hier an zwei neue Leute, die ein Nerdfight machen und zwar kommen jetzt Huerto Rick Ostler und Max West Weiss und bringen mit Strange Games, Funky Sings, Legendary, Rock'n'RnB und noch viele mehr. Ich bin wirklich gespannt, was das wird und wünsche euch mit den beiden auf jeden Fall eine schöne Nacht und sage Tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht immer schön eure Pack-Ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.
Ich hab auch schon zehn Jahre her, Export 2000, es ist nicht mehr ganz so aktuell.